je vais vite vite remédier à ça vite
vite vite vite vite ouf
on a réussi
c'est le plus important femme qui vient
d'être fait parce que sinon on peut pas
bien regardé quoi ah bah oui on
souffrirait donc on a le raid on n'a pas
les calmes peut-être aujourd'hui ce
serait dommage mais ce serait pas si
grave notre façon dans la came la plus
importante pour aujourd'hui
donc y'a pas de soucis on va aller voir
l'échiquier fab exact donc c'est
vraiment le gros le gros choc un
aujourd'hui c'est la partie qu'on va
regarder
quasiment uniquement on verra on
pourrait faire un tour ailleurs
lorsqu'il se passe car si oui on peut
faire un truc et donc petrov pas de
surprise juste mon doute c'était ce que
kara n'allait pas peut-être jouer des
quatre autre chose ça irait mais il
fallait peut-être l'énergie à l'énergie
terrestre qui a pas suffit peut-être
pour préparer des 4 contre n'est pas bon
non il connaît bien la petrov il a joué
lui même c'était un des pionniers et
leaders de droite pionner pense ça date
un peu avant mais il l'a remis au goût
du jour récemment un truc ouais c'était
un pionnier moderne quoi voilà
là on il nous manque le coup il a
sûrement joué des quatre coups des trois
et on a déjà vu un dans ce tournant a vu
tous les coups ils sont élus cavalli c6
on a vu fou au set on a vu le fou des
six pardon et fouette 5 voilà et il faut
se tenir une caisse on a tous vu on va
voir ce que n'est pas décide de jouer
bas je dirais fou des six familles qui
se lève qui va faire un tour il connaît
l'importance de cette partie le joueur à
mittal aux américains
à ces chrétienne bacrot
on va bien voir
ja etienne non mais sous
[Musique]
aïe aïe aïe ah ouais la salle et nuire
fa bow et une belle croix bien changé
boys ça allait nuire quand même assez
fortement la qualité du stream way
heureusement que heureusement que tu
l'as vu fab barinov après deux minutes
de piètre qualité enfin on peut démarrer
a bien écrit par tina front pu cia écrit
fab libye on est très bien fab il ya le
petit logo de chasse comme un en bas à
droite aussi qui vient
quand même en
délire en juillet un peu ce live moi je
fais le mien lie avec le logo on peut
mieux sur le pion des cinq when
the logo l'adoption
celui-ci s'est bouffé ya plus la pub
mais sinon il a toute la partie mais
arles un centre de l'échiquier va avoir
et bossa jarcy le logo c'était le pion
aux deux bombes à plus de pub après dix
secondes battant pis mais il faudrait
aussi le logo concurrents s.com près de
la petite tête de robert s quoi
c'est quand qu'on a une fois qu'on a vu
les blancs gagné contre la petrov ça a
vraiment l'air béton dans l'autre soir
un oubli de ces
battues c'est ça date ça va être dit a
pas si longtemps
ben c'est dur de battre la petrov et
écoute on va voir si faibles une idée
donc c'était fou des trois fous des six
ro rog c-46 il a joué tour eu un bref si
nicolas cavallier c3 qui est possible
ayew dame b 3 de richard non il n'y
avait pas tout re oui avait pas toi oui
c'est à la place d'après trois rouges et
le touriste et 3 aussi à tours 1 c'est
un des grands coups
ça c'était le match
karlsson l'epo c'est très possible ouais
ouais c'est elle est partie du match
en fait au moins là y'a pus g4 il vient
de bien revenir au f5 ne sais pas pour
repartir en g4 le coup d'après donc on
attaque bessette mais est-ce qu'on
attaque vraiment quoi après ça c'est à
voir je vais regarder un peu les parties
on vous a donné des infos de première
main
ouais ouais ouais non c'était ça c'était
le match et ici je me rappelle plus quel
était le coût n'est pas du cavaly assise
dans le règne du roi jean
dame 17 ouais c'était peut-être d'amd
c'est râpé mais cette fameuse variantes
de raguet oui
je crois que c'est ici quelque part à la
variante de la guerre d'un bébé droit
d'amener cette
la partie karlsson n'est pas où je vous
la donne et d'amd cette crise et trois
cas et c3po f5 2005
et stella leur a guère c'était d'amener
cette date mais c'est là où tu joues
avec la dame oui les pièces même 17 si
tu fais dame prend 17 heures ndp et
milhouse railleur non c'est pas la
rigueur
et la rigueur avec ses bad as me 17 sec
et valeo 4 oui c'est qu'il va livrer
c'est ça c'est qu'il y aura lieu quatre
dames à huit voies la donne et les 17
maintenant ça c'est la rigueur ça
comme des sept
cdc des tours 4 kgs ces six dames et
fuit 3 et fluide tours 2 ouais c'est ça
c'est l'arrière f6 g5 machin est radieux
raid et les noirs ils vont ça c'est leur
agger les amis graves à l'encontre
nguyen deux joueurs
tchèques chaque coin chaque année
viennent
il a fait cavalier h4
donc
trois dames 17 du coup qu'il a joué
contre eux mais cachent quatre bons pas
vraiment nouveauté mais pseudo une seule
partie dans la base une partie
u14 slovène donc autant dire c'est
quasiment une nouveauté du qatar entre
roseman et belle sac lévy roseman dans
mitidja mitigé
14h30 quoi sa clique au hasard qu'ils
avaient fait parce qu'on y avait 17
cents contre 16 cents et donc cavalli h4
jouer bon ben ok au moins ils doivent
guider fabi c'est terrible en fait ils
ont eu 14 u 14 slovène tu te rend les
coups de fady cola nouveautés on va voir
lui savait pas pourquoi le jouer mais
bon c'est pas grave ça tekken dégoûté si
tu as les noirs comme un fou
et au quesne époque et a fléchi dont il
n'a pas le coup
apple qu'on stocke après je pense pas
que ça va révolutionner la ligne puisque
magnus aurait eu oui bien sûr par contre
je vois une idée pratique et
avoir a priori fort qu elles font eu six
enfants ces plots gars de char ou glitch
le match
bientôt le tour de france
est-ce que la plus longue étape du tour
de france qu'est-ce qui est le plus long
entre la plus longue étape du tour de
france est la plus longue partie des
candidats est plus longue partie des
candidats et surnom quand j'ai abordé un
truc je pense aussi mais bon pas sûr
ouais bon alors on vous apprécierez
lâche 4 les blancs veulent juste
encaissé la paire de fou quoi et au
passage tu prennes 5 d'un prêt sans y
aurait un problème sur sorbet satire
apparaissent alors certes ça d'accra f2
peut-être un petit fou prend 1,4 au
passage ou quoi donc a priori faut
sauver souhaité foule aussi semble
logique alors certes on peut perdre un
pion
après faut quatre ans tandis que je
fasse un petit truc fable hockey fait
donc
avant de fortement très ya un petit
il ya eu un petit bug avec le démarrage
du youtube chose que youtube chasse
comme mais c'est bon maintenant ah bah
il a démarré mais pas au bon endroit
donc du coup
il faut que
que je leurs dames 1 en neuf tournois un
truc en fait ouais c'est ça arrive
je sais pas si je vais pouvoir
essayer
en espérant que ça fonctionne mais bon
après toute façon faut que revenir sur
twitter moyens peu le chat je sais pas
si ça a réussi à modifier ou pas on se
veut différent du doigt
parce que t'as pas que ce bouton
après on se rend sur la partie juste
complexe
et quoi
je serai mal écrits rendus lycées masse
ajustait mal écrire et ça l'a pas mis au
bon endroit goyer comme sur youtube oui
il est quand même
ok là ça va être bon
parfait réussi fable désolé
ouais donc je reprends manqué h45 le fou
prend le nom faut aussi ce et les blancs
au bond ont l'occasion de gagner un pion
s'ils veulent chez passé une bonne idée
parce que table et 5
et à perdre de fouet tu as donné carte
blanche aux thèmes la casse des cinq
très vite
bon je sais pas peut-être que ces jets
d'oeuf avides d'efforts nhtsa ne répond
plus je sais pas ça ça m'a l'air vicié
on a envie de voir une autre idée que ça
mais bon
cash 4 ou 6 qu'est-ce qu'on ad'autres
dessus
cavalli c3 maintenant c'est trop
maintenant peut-être mais bon
après ses 3
hop
sortir ce qu'ils vivent ici voilà et à
l'air c'est pas fracassant quoi caillage
quatre arrivées l'amener vers f5
peut-être faire des trucs alors
ok je demande à voir je sais pas on va
essayer de mettre t'attend grand écran
pour voir n'est pas imposant comme
toujours devant l'échiquier
ouais c'est en toute chose ils sont
encore huitième partie a pris 10 c'est
avec ce huitième partirai mais c'est
vrai que ça ça j'aime tellement
il ya un truc qui est pas il ya un
update que j'ai faits qui n'est pas
passée en fait face à sa fille je sais
juste que non mais en fait c'est 6 en 1
qui est pas passé il ya les deux en fait
c'est logique en fait
voir et non à désole un pouvoir
ça devait serait très gênant fab non
mais
bon voilà
on va bien le neuf
réfléchis né pauvre j'arrive à
comprendre quand il fait ça ça le fait
chier s'ils essayent de se rappeler ses
calculs je n'ai pas trop l'aref de son
langage corporel
donc c'est pas trop j'ai pas entendu
sont particulièrement inquiets non plus
il se fait chier quoi autres caches 4 de
merde non
encore ce coût de merde j'ai pas révisé
tellement c'est faible
soissons qui a perdu contre nakamura le
streamer
ses bonnes avec la quand même s'ils
gagnent
on peut aller voir je suis bien sûr des
autres on y réfléchit surtout d'un canon
way oui c'est vrai que dit à quoi
d'autre ding junhui
oui hélas un grand écran j'y réfléchis
en ce qu'ils y atteignent ici
à sa tâche risquée côté radio bon temps
naka
qui joue là bas rhinoise haut niveau va
pas le provoquer quoi
on a qu'un qui joue pas particulièrement
risqué aujourd'hui c'est à dire que si
null null quoi ouais ouais mais là
peut-être raison que demain il ya le
title comme il a déjà annoncé qu'il
voyait et qu'il le stream est qu'il le
commente est bien évidemment fab
l'événement phare de ces trois semaines
et carouge jours mais en vrai de demain
s'ils jouent à 17h en vrai cheval tatin
stream on suit carreaux qui fait le
title c'est tellement hilarant bonjour
c'est de jouer quoi ouais on va essayer
de le battre et ducasse et sa confiance
pour le canada regardez ils jouent les
candidats nous ont gagné 1 0
ah c'est beau quoi
ce que gauthier magnus qu'il le joue
aussi mais moi aussi je le title regarde
beaucoup plus intéressantes les
candidats j'écoute année peau qui vient
ici je t'emmerde mais aussi fils à ça ça
me paraît assez fou en fait je l'aï
talent ouais ouais mais c'est beau non
non moi ça me fait marrer mais on s'en
fout
je trouve ça juste hallucinant en fait
ça me prouve qu'ils ont vraiment bien
besoin du jour de repos quand même ouais
important
ceja pendant le tour de france tu as ton
jour de repos parce que tu en as she
vend dix jours et tu vas aller faire un
petit critérium je sais pas où
l'histoire donne quoi
non mais je vais venir mais c'est
vraiment ça la différence et surtout
faire chier sur votre critère je peux
gagner le sprint
mais en fait je pense pas aux gars de
char il pourrait un
regard fait monter l'alpe d'huez je
crois des 100 j'arrive
il a sûrement un contrat non bien sûr
que non mais il aime bien jouer les
miens fermant sa chaîne et les modes
psam et la personne infectée personne
n'a envie de lui imposer sa boîte
enfin non non c'est pas possible
il à engrenages aide ou alors ils aiment
bien les thaïs agence a rien promis mais
bien sûr mais c'est
franchement
mais c'est beau
oui c'est beau dont la
non mais moi je dis tu vois souvent
blame the game the players quoi c'est
eux qui font des jours de repos à
rallonge qui
bosse à n'importe quoi voilà c'est pour
ça un verre du coût d'un cas il un jour
de repos qui sert à rien baidu son
traducteur il joue son title il a bien
raison puis c'est marrant et où puis je
crois qu'il a un côté un peu mégalo naka
très clairement on en
a ça fait partie du personnage moi je
kiffe bien ce truc là après c'est sûr
qu'à une grosse remise en question sur
les jours de repos là très clairement
parce que si un des joueurs peut se
permettre ça c'est que en fait il ya
trois jours de repos et concrètement
c'est vrai qu'un repos tous les trois
jours ça ça paraît beaucoup mais
côté vous pouvez gallo bah oui ça fait
partie du personnage un personnage
hikaru
c'est un personnage
rapporte six routes ja
du l2 bat une nouvelle fois fab
ce qui est des 4
donc c'est aussi nantis berlinoise et le
cavalier cointreau
bafoue b6 normalement on va être jouée
par richie pour faire ces six ensuite et
c'est bon on verra ok
et c'est quoi être apportées à ces
digues pour regarder juste pour voir
ouais mais après il ya deux parties qui
servent à rien aujourd'hui et deux
parties qui servent qu en gros
enfin pour eux elles servent pour les
jouera le serbe mais pour nous trading
tout dallas ils sont vraiment les deux
éliminés encore rapporte si gagner
on doit pouvoir beaucoup mais il est pas
con oui si mais non enfin ouais on doit
y avoir un truc incroyable mais
meding duda et firent ouja c'est à dire
errajhi sais c'est vraiment termina
docquois
de finito
alors qu'est ce qui nous fait le dépôt
c'est quand même vraiment n'est point
sur quoi ça jusqu'en fait signer pro
gagne aujourd'hui ce qui serait étonnant
avec avec les noirs messine est pauvre
venait à gagner il a gagné le tournoi en
fait france
alors faut six dames ces deux
là je pense qu'il va vouloir faire le f
singh qu un j'avais pas été joués of
things koztoujours compromettant mais
peut-être par duda mai mais qu'on avait
vue intéressant dans les petrov en
réalité
alors qu'est ce qui est vu comme échange
de pièces dans la partie de dubai appuyé
fou de caisse blanche
c'est jean coutu tentèrent bien mais bon
c'est jouable ouais mais tu sais que moi
j'avais aussi joué à comment il
s'appelle hacker salafa c'était aussi
une prépa et c'était aussi un lifting co
et c'était aussi père dangereux pour les
blancs et g et c'était au boom petrov
j'ai pas l'impression de plein de fois
dense et petrov voir que f 5e pasqua
assez étonnant je suis d'accord avec toi
même et chasser ce fait troisième cas de
figure en fait déjà
bah ça devient fin c'est plus un hasard
à partir d'un moment donné non mais
j'avais déjà vu délivrer 5 bat en fait
j'avais joué un peu là petrov en 2006
je vais étudier des trucs et
on avait perdu nous pas non oui s'ils
avaient perdu une seule et en avait
gagné une ou pas oui beau score alors
pourquoi tard été défaits contre groupe
maxime aussi avec la petrov
pourquoi j'ai arrêté je sais pas des
fois je comprends pas ce que je fais
dans mes choix d'ouverture il est rue
que j'ai regardé que les plus jamais
rejouer sa raison non j'aille à une
partie très facilement avec les noirs
contre estrie kovic grand maître serbe
bon c'était droit ronde du matin mais
effet le court j'avais perdu contre omar
edwards
en 2007 je crois
et je sais pas combien j'en ai joué mais
pas tant que ça un bac 6 5 et peut-être
à huy donc en fait je n'ai quasiment pas
joué mais pas peut-être
ça va
peut-être permettre du coup
tu as toi chez moi enfin c'est pas trés
petrov qua non ça te
bon le bourbon votre âge on va dire toi
j'en sais rien je sais pas quand je
rejoue spécialement je gère la petrov tu
la joues contenu hl te déplaît pas comme
moi je joue beaucoup d' open c'est pas
si souvent que ok t'es sur quelque
partie importante ça peut être pas mal
de la voir après deux nuls c'est
toujours bien même contre plus faibles
ça dépend quel plus faible c'est vrai
donc je préfère jouer des trucs risqué
parce que je me dis aucun moment il va
quand même il va quand même jouer à son
niveau colonel
mois nul je prends toujours
n'auraient pas accès à 300 points
d'écart ou si mais si fabien
mais du coup voilà petrov jamais bien ça
m'avait l'air correct quoi je veux dire
après bah ouais je t'ai moins avancé que
ces gens là et puis maintenant c'est du
tellement à la mode que tu vas enfin
tout ce que j'ai fait à l'épaule s'offre
la poubelle et retravailler
bon je travaille plus trop quoi donc on
ne reverra pas sur une petrov
faut jamais rêvé mais là bon pas de
sitôt et rohff inventé d'ailleurs par un
joueur qui s'appelait petrov alors
est-ce que tu connais la logique de
l'ouverture oui intéressant c'est russe
assez les russes
à l'époque il y avait une philosophie
les échecs se rapprocher de ce qui se
passait en stratégie militaire
par exemple philidor 1
les pions sont l'âme des échecs hu est
arrivé la démocratie un non mais
vraiment fait horreur oui non mais c'est
pas des conneries attention wave
programme des échecs ou i révolution
donc c'est vraiment pour ça en fait
récent théâtre regarde le peuple il est
là il peut dégager donc fulham des
échecs importants et la petrov bas les
guerres napoléoniennes
tiens tu attaques moscou avec moi je te
contre-attaquerons garazi prend le jeu
dégage mais je vous fais ton g de
bouffer par ici on regarde plus pareil
maintenant déjà récupéré par et qu'est
ce qu'on fait accords de paix fait très
attention mais oui mais du coup
c'est derrière cette petrov ya cette
philosophie on fait pas que défendre
fait contre attaque contre attaques web
de la chasse de la bérézina en fait la
chasse de napoléon par les cosaques
russes
tu vas laisser intéresser quelqu'un ce
petit intermède
historique et donc qui a été inventé par
un célèbre joe afp de petrov et
d'ailleurs on l'appelle aussi la défense
russe oui
hachey corinne on a beaucoup joué sinon
je sais pas maintenant mais pas bonne
ouverture plein de joueurs l'ont joué
même bizarre qu'ils payent plus
peut-être mais jarre karpov laval à son
répertoire il avait joué des ragas riz
et vice versa il me semble dans le match
moment là beaucoup moins vu un mets
d'ailleurs est ce que pour continuer
dans les métaphores échec aux
militaires est ce que finalement
aujourd'hui les ordinateurs qu'ils ne
dominent les échecs ne serait pas
précurseur d'une ère où les ordinateurs
comme les robots chiens non mais
dominerait même la stratégie militaire
plus globalement
c'est une bombe à cet endroit tu vas
tuer tant de personnes ils rataient la
réaction toi tu fais des yeux tu
calcules ce qu'est ce que c'est pas un
[Musique]
prémonitoire du nerf ou ou les
ordinateurs décideront tout pour nous
jusque
jusque là peut-être pousser la réflexion
tu vois or on l'a vu dans plein de truc
de science fiction
qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent le chat est
ce qu'ils sont philosophes aujourd'hui
on ce lundi à bat là on a les meilleurs
on a envoyé tout le monde au boulot à
pop up aujourd'hui à un moment j'en à
quel point c'est si important d'être
juste
[Musique]
jacques productif ou
comment dire
tirer sur la corde pour tout faire au
mieux au détriment peut-être du
bien-être d'autres fins pire on fait pas
le truc parfait on s'en fout ce que dit
leur dit quoi
mais ce système là du tout optimisé au
mais ce système est plus efficace
mais son fragile au sein de rendre
rendre les scellés les autres obsolète
très souvent mais c'est fragile
des fois tu voir des sites anti fragile
et marchent très bien bon et ça marche
peut-être pas au top en temps normaux
mais en temps de crise a tout d'un coup
ils surperforment
alors on est très bien l'aca surperforme
fab
mais l'optimisation en fait lydia et
nous permet déjà d'optimiser pas mal de
choses on a dit courante par exemple
l'étrager en gpa ce
qui passe par les embouteillages jewel
je vais plus vite ça nous permet déjà
d'optimiser quand même ça va vite ça que
j'ai raison que ça rentre quoi ce truc
qu'après tu sais plus de diriger puis
m'a pas dit de voitures prendre un sens
interdit parce que j'ai pas cet avis et
cuisez part mis à jour mais ça change il
ya trois jours et que tu utilises plus
ton cerveau tu sais plus trop peur et
dans une ville c'est pas la même chose
encore une fois les échecs prémonitoire
à force d'analysé que avec l'ordi où
dans le monde une voix nous rien je vois
plus rien ne m'est réellement voiture
elle a encore tué par un net échec vie
réelle donc la tension ne sait plus
qu'est ce qu'on regarde vraiment
est ce que ce serait pas un affrontement
ne sait plus à sa part très loin
tu retiens pas la route si tu retiens
pas les ouvertures toute analyse alors
dit à tes fichiers tu ne te sort un
petit coup que t'as pas dessus c'est pas
mal et tu fais contresens direct fouet
par contre si tu as accès au gps non la
partie qui serait beaucoup plus fort
sera barrée à najib estime 10
[Rires]
toi tu crois
ouais ce que les alouettes grande bête
non mais tu as et des discussions
philosophiques qu'on pourrait se
permettre d'avoir sur un tournoi des
candidats femme j'aimerais bien ça qui
est des petits noms mais aussi la
question finalement à les attacher à ça
c'est
non c'est ce que enfin qu'est ce qu'on
appelle le projet
parce que tu peux optimisée des choses
ou quoi mais ce que province est plus
heureux juste être plus optimisée et
quelque part tu veux dire que ce qu'on
s'amusait pas plus aux échecs mais les
pales et d'ordinateurs finalement on
joue mieux mais on se fait chier
quand on regarde les parties on voit le
trucage gas gas golfe bah je sais pas
quand tu regardes à l'époque juste les
mecs mais il avait plus de respect pour
eux parce que tu dis waouh c'est
impressionnant fait de là tu te dis
ouais bon ils font qu'il faut que les
coûts de merde en fait quoi
alors je prends genre on voit même dans
chat souvent quoi tu vois et
je pense que ouais en fait de suivre des
partis avec laure 10 et on perd un truc
mais on perd en émotions ont cherché à
comprendre pourquoi il a fait ça machin
on regrettait pas tous vont essayer là
on est très très spectateurs très passif
dont on a même voulu en rallongeant les
cadences comme on l'a fait tout faire
progresser aux échecs mais en vrai on se
fait chier
battue avant c'est un jeu de café c'est
un jeu f5 où il faut se perfectionner la
vérité de la position est perdue se rend
compte qu'on l'a pas du tout tu vois
c'est alors qu'avant c'était un jeu dans
les bouts de bois tu éduques la jet set
était très heureux les mecs se
retrouvent dans des bars bars cafés de
la régence à paris mais c'est papa que
dans le monde entier avec des barres
comme ça mnm des matchs par
correspondance entre bar un
extraordinaire bombes arrivent et warta
peintre explique al koussour enveloppe
et finalement à vouloir tout
perfectionner mais le truc c'est que tu
fasses en maintenant sa lancée
s'élançait ont fait une discussion comme
ça mais on pourra plus revenir en
arrière là dessus qu'on
est peut-être tant mieux d'ailleurs
c'est comme ça fab la vie continue
rien ni team oxbow s'adapter au début
j'avais un truc comme ça rien et
immobile la planète même sur laquelle on
est enfin tu vas t en mouvement
perpétuel mouvement douce en fait quand
tu réfléchis tf bref en fait on fait des
loopings là on est là
non bref je rends pas compte en fait
on va très vite en bouche pas quoi de
kilomètres ont fait à la seconde mais en
fait on est là on n'avance pas parce qu
il ya des gens qui ont regardé des
téléskis font quoi ces coûts
[Rires]
relaxe
du tout évident qu'on à 700 kilomètres
heure à 1620 oui mais en fait on paye en
plus on tourne pas être en même temps sa
loi aux centrifugeuses le truc quoi
hôpital soleil qui bombardent de lumière
pas champs électromagnétiques qui
élaguent web même la ville via la lune
quoi
tourner autour quoi
se révolter c'est de l'anti moustique
dgac
et d'air tu vois toujours la même face
de la lune ça tout ça mais ça c'est une
bonne grille
de l'autre côté à nontron sait pas
vraiment où sébastien mais il ya des
gens qui savent qu'ils sont allés
prendre des photos ils ont fait des
trucs ou personnes sont ainsi 11 y en a
qui savent mais très peu et non mais ce
qui nous ont vraiment faim on ne sait
pas mais c'est bon on fait que pouvoir
l'autre côté de la vie sauvage et de
prendre une fusée est sûre pas explorer
un peu faire des petits bonds
mais la face cachée de la lune c'est
magnifique en fait ça a été magnifique
en fait
en fait elle a aucune rotation sur elle
même si je crois qu'il ya une rotation
m'est égal avec lui alors exactement
bref on regarde tu tournes je tourne
aussi connaît
je me cache
s'arrêter vous qu'il ya des mecs qui
vivent derrière
il y ait su exactement où ils devaient
pas aller tiens on va pas se montrer si
on revient nous faire chier
côté
et c'est le solaire se déplace dans la
galaxie à 650 me km/heure sa fonction il
ya plus d'un an des jo en fait c'est le
tir dans un monde qui bouge aussi vite
finalement c'est normal d'avancé
enfin en tout cas elle a joué à troyes
et il veut pas voir cahier b4y c'est
pour votre niveau il va se poser toutes
ces questions oui est-ce que je dois
vraiment répéter leur titre i compliqué
à trois ils jettent la petite turbine
as-tu vient un moment où f 5 ça devient
très candide à quoi il a fait face à un
vrai mais tu vois on en parlait avant
mais je crois que la votation t'as pas
mis le choix parce que
il va te vas te faire remarquer ici
trois toute façon il va te faire c'est
sky à partir il ya des fourrages cet
échec intermédiaire tu as promis d'aller
en rave 6 face aux rouges et 5 c'est
juste désagréable
j'ai voulu aller plus vite que la
musique
bon il ya trop de pions quoi well et
punta allen autre chose puntos donc
ouais du coup faire f 5
mais j'ai vraiment l'impression que dans
beaucoup de ces petrov c'est un coup
thématiques qui comprend des cinq tempo
de fabi c'est bien il est très bien
préparée ouais je sais pas où ça va nous
mener un vrai qu'il a mis une belle
chemise
a pris l'option prend mais aussi le
ad on peut soupçonner un peu le cas
veillez à six mois sans qu'ils aient
dominé
peut-être c3 ou je sais pas quoi mais tu
menaces rien bon je serai un jour au
japon je me place mais
bon la fare échanger les bonnes pièces
on voit
ça va pas être loin des galles mais
peut-être du f3 et
complexe
bon en gros à
jarque f6
jessains appelés à fermer en bus à
votre envie de prendre direct à tourner
et qu'on
fait des cd key ces trois gars c'est
cette f3 je pense qu'il connaît encore
un hulk ou faux je suis pas sur mais bon
il a l'air tellement tranquille ça qui
joue vite
catherine ouest ah ok bon ça ça calme
top qui promeuvent 5 ça donne tout
reprend
vous prendre un prend quoi à 100
dans l'âge d'homme h4 ok je veux
vraiment gagner ça c'est sûr qu'ils la
famille dans le règne
c'est en fait la position c'est décidé
après je sais pas comment tu peux amener
ça mais faut voir
donc des f3 ça fait quoi
toujours s'en prendre au piège 92e il
fait important pour le dard cette
ressource mais longue mais bon après
logique de l'avoir dans le sens où le
cavaliere il est parti il a beau faire
de faire le malin pour le mariole
ok bon
ok comment faire face justement
question donc c'est décidé attend il
joue qu'à et c3
peut-être
le tempo fabien voilà qu'est c3 sait
faire
bon au moins il propose quelque chose
famille je veux dire ok sera pas révisée
la petrov bien sûr mais
est ok ils forcent les pots à réfléchir
un peu par lui-même a pas juste c'est
une prépa comme contre rapporte là on
voit qu'il a déjà pris une demi-heure
pour jeu ses coûts alors il est pas du
tout mal autant il jauge de 14 coups
tout va très bien mais
[Musique]
ok de l'eufor ça me fait réfléchir
on aura des cas ici c'est peut-être je
sais pas est ce que tour à s'éviter un
coup tu peux aussi pour faire adopter
par b 8 6
après ça que les gens adoreraient phare
f3 mais si ça marche jamais à cause des
dames 7 slash fawcett
s'écoule point mort
tout cas est né pauvre
qui a pas les 20 qui connaît peut-être
pas les coups qui s'en rappellent passe
avec une langue très mineur a pris là
forcément regarder pour son match ce qui
valait h4 c'est sûr ils ont jugé
regarder tellement de choses
il a forcément dû la voir un jour dans
un fichier mais après de là à s'en
rappeler il ya quand même un mondain
après gilles carle a quand même du bien
réviseurs
s'il a fini vite
et
c'était quand même probable que quatre
après il va rire des d4 un peu oui
il a peut-être passé un peu profité au
passé un peu de temps etc signé jane a
aussi un
possible on s'est pas en fait on sait
pas mais bon j'espère que
j'espère que vous en faites
en tout cas là nul serait un résultat
parfait 1 pour un beau dépouille royale
fine des yeux fermés pour nous
il se rapprocherait il ferait un grand
pas vers la victoire avec une nulle
aujourd'hui fait assez et je
savais me dans les coups qu'on est là
évidemment me disent tous qu'ils y
jouent vite mais comme c'est un dépôt
parce que si on peut avoir
alors j'espère pour famille qu'il l'a
encore dans ses 8 peut-être pas
mais bon ce n'est peut-être pas le coup
de l'ordi après c'est un des coups les
plus logiques 1
c'est hyper c'est pour ça que je dis
j'espère qu'ils la fin j'espère pour lui
bonsoir moi signer pro gagne ça me va
jeudi c'est immérité mérite
puis en plus ancré en 4e
série h 4
alors la turbine est elle kiffe kiffe f3
elle kiffe f3 way est faux et tu dis
qu'ils sont fous des trucs kathak
lecavalier donc on avait plusieurs choix
de talent par les deux dames 7
j'ai trois cavaliers pranger 3 cette
fois ça peut être trop bon puis on prend
vous prend 4,9 cinq
tours prend pour francis intérieur c'est
çà et là tout renseignement qui fait mal
d'un projet si souvent f5 peut-être
demain
on
entend déjà une pièce de plus en fait
ok bon plus de davos est déjà éliminée
et tour qu'on réussisse d'un match 4
f 4g pas d'un match de hockey
hockey fawcett l'eau de manière
d'attaquer h4
attend fawcett s'affole pas trop
il la f3 jouer tempo donc c'est qu'il a
joué beaucoup trop vite pour pour pas
que ce soit après pas
bon il faut au stade à l'heure d'aller
en fait c'est pas au début il n'aimait
pas et
savard 29 30
ils trouvent ça ok fawcett j'ai trouvé
dix fois et 6
1 cette idée qu'on a vu déjà un peu tout
à l'heure
non ça c'est dur franchement s'il n'est
pas il n'a pas trouvé sa ff
vous prend à six fours prend des quatre
fous des trophées 3par dont
tour autour des 1 et 10 17 00 mais bon
ouais non non ça faut il va super
content avec muse de moi ça moi je
pensais que tu viens avec les blancs en
fait tu dis tu as vu les 2 kg de papa et
le coup sûr cases blanches ses deux
pions sur case lange le bloc il est
vraiment très faible tu sais fabien à ce
fauchage et 3.600 deuxième coup saison
10 déjà
et si tu fais ni il faut cette dame cet
équipage a recueilli procès 3 qui peut
être un coup quand même baissé tu te dis
tiens je vais à faiblir un peu ça
rime plutôt pas trop mal puisque tu
attaques f5 en fait un tataki tu mets
une pression sur f5 tâter des tories
celles jetterait faut prendre ce cas les
cases noires ghz à faut qu'ils arrivent
donc à ssf iv qu as tu viens ansari kiev
4 [ __ ] broich un
étal faut aussi pourri avec les deux
pions des 5 f 5 1 au quesne et baudoin
devoir être bon bah il peut trouver
fourguer bien
un pack à roanne a son idée sur ce qu'il
trouve fawcett faut des gars tu fais une
pièce jeu de pions et puis je sais pas
quoi c'est une belle prépa quoi imposer
du coup il a il est il avait tort c'est
8 le coût humain il n'a pas croisé les
couleurs du
hockey incroyable voilà partis dire
quelle est la réponse
bourges j'imagine qu'il n'a pas trouvé
hier soir ça mais c'est sûr mais je veux
dire de réviser de son rap est tombé
dedans d'avoir lé envie d'avoir envie
alors ça c'est sûr qu'il a envie
ou quoi là pas du tout hein surtout que
roanne a cette façon ça peut jouer dans
la partie même s'il a une bonne position
à un moment c'est qui vient de sortir
deux parties de 6 à fond ouais mais
c'est impressionnant quand même l'action
du champion quand même en temps de jeu
il a beaucoup plus jouer que des pots de
rendre tendrait tecan même impressionné
l'attesté complètement sur le cul non
mais non en fait il nous a habitués à
faire des belles prépare après des fois
je tombe pas dans ton pas dedans et là
ça tombe bien il a une idée et c'est
intéressant et
ça fait plaisir il a réussi à en faire
en une partie ce que ce que carlson n'a
pas réussi à faire ouais c'est fort
et paf au cette session roi fou aux sept
fois f6 oui c'est sûr oui vous pouvez ou
à défaut cette salle où tu peux voir
mais j'ai trois en fait france 4 on a
regardé cgp rang est allé cases noires
et c'est pas terrible donc faut faire
fouet cette foule f6
pas facile battus ville une pièce en
fait pour des compensations pas si
évidente et ça se trouve c'est un truc
égal comme lors d'it d'hier ça allait
bien caruana contre les carreaux dès que
tu dérapes un coup paf tu passes à 1,50
donc si caruana gagne aujourd'hui
attention mesdames et messieurs
ladies and gentleman ça peut resserrer
tout le monde en tête et ça remet tout
le monde en cours sans ça peut même être
un porte tu vas d'épaulé plus dans la
peau là il est pas bien en mêlée a
fléchi il regrette peut-être sa petite
de rodières
wacey regrette non mais y'a ok ça va
c'est pas
quand il fait plus grimace l'a
appris il boxe pas dans la même
catégorie les 2 janvier et comme une
belle différence de n'en rien qui est
plus mobile les frappes sont plus
lourdes aux côtés à wayne on avis faut
pas qu'ils s'en prennent une fabiano sa
peau elle le mettre ko
pas bien et pau dr c'est autorisé je
suis bleu je crois déjà vu le h avec ces
bleus ou blancs du coup et peut-être
rouge l'as bari important non mais vous
faites là chez lui ce qu'ils veulent si
tu me trouves chemise noire et je crois
pas d'accord
et je suis pas sûr mais je crois pas moi
je suis ami wayne toi je sais pas si ça
passerait fab elle est pas uni
je suis très bonne qualité de tissu
chemise hawaïenne
en tout cas ça sue côté dépôt
auprès vaut le coup de s'y trouve toute
la défense a tué juste bravo et puis
voir mes trucs à hilla c'est bien c'est
bien tout cas ce qu'il a à faire dans
l'ouverture aux familles ça va trouver
un truc à faire
c'était vraiment pas facile lorsqu'il
était plate et dépose sur sur la petrov
a passé six mois à analyser ça pour le
match contre comme carlson bref il en
souriant il a été très solide un but
d'audard aussi très solide pense qu'on
aurait espéré un côté affirment déjà
contre les petrov c'est ce qu'est en
train de faire fabiano ici
gay j'y perds préparer fabi c'est pas
hyper étonnant
oui non rien n'est pas aussi enfin je
veux dire puis famille toi dans le
tournoi il n'a pas planté des trucs à
chaque ronde
mais il connaît bien et sur les grosses
parties là est souvent
il ya des idées quoi voilà ça travail du
côté famille
n'est pas l'occasion de montrer qu'il
est bien au dessus du tournoi ou alors
ça montrera qu'il ya de la place pour
une bataille pour la première place ben
ouais c'est un peu ça en fait voilà six
paires en fait ça enfin s'armer brassard
rebat les cartes sont
là toutes les cartes sont rebattues 1
bat déjà caruana égalité avec les peaux
et ça remet complètement le h2 dans
aussi bon après derrière un mais il
n'est pas si loin mais non enfin sur
hier il s'est donné un motif d'espoir
mais
normalement c'est déjà un écart quand
même hein
c'est sûr
à moins qu'ils gagnent aujourd'hui assis
gagner aujourd'hui mais je ouverture j'y
crois pas trop
tout est toujours possible
mike leake pas pour le moment
qu'est ce que c'est que ce fou qu'il
était parti qui revenait à sordo
ok de plus il y en a sept un bien fou
radi qui jouent le jeu encore une fois
non parce que je veux dire peut-être
qu'au douzième coup
quand il fait soleil darde ses fans
il peut faire tomber 5 et juste faire
des répètes quoi
que l'attitude de radjabov un job style
joue vraiment plus rien dans le tournoi
mais il y joue aux échecs il clic clic
fab non mais c'est pas mal de le voir
jouer cliquer ouais ouais c'est à dire
qu'il aurait pu juste faire nul 10 10
hockey de son qu'est ce que je vaux plus
rien je m'en fiche attend la fin du
tournoi maintenant il joue et c'est bien
l'attitude et cliquer sans rien attendre
lui qui a tout prendre
et s'en aller
tu t'en vas toi tu cliques et tu pars
ouais écoute c'est des belles parties un
ménéz paul n'est pas dans le dur
il a pas l'air très heureux là quand
même
oui c'était super chien là ça se voit
alors ils peuvent pas prétendre chocapic
d'offre jusqu'au bout
c'est en ça que tu peux dire que wes
avec le site à ma nomination sont pas si
mal parce que le gars qui ont pls et ben
il sera remplaçant naturel juste perdu
son tour il rentrera chez lui où il est
forcé à jouer pendant trois semaines
ouais de s'imposer ça est d'imposer sa
au public
mais bon tu vois moi genre à de boeuf et
n'a pas l'air d'être si malheureux
aujourd'hui
tracer avec dépouille doit être pas bien
pour le coup grande marche la whey prend
du retard il n'a pas beaucoup joué hier
mais pas ils devaient s'attendre à une
fin mais c'est pas parce que tu t'y
attends tu t'es prêt failli c'est que ça
va arriver mais c'est pas où ni comment
tu fais ce que tu peux pour regarder un
peu tout ce qui
ce que tu peux quoi mais c'est mc ionisé
un coup inattendu le top a battu l'as
pas quoi
dire
un boxeur esprit and what we meet
vraiment s'attendre à ce qu'ils se
prennent rate un oui mais
cela prend
je savais qu'il allait servir très fort
je m'y attendais
pourquoi tu contre isner en trois
temps montagne au vélo bah tu prends la
route paul gâche artus avec les rouler
vite battait la cua est prêt il n'y a
pas trop m c'est vrai quoi tu te
préparer
ce qui a fait augmenter les performances
bon je sais pas je peux pas convaincu
un ice bar effets secondaires du café je
pense qu'il va chier la
non mais y'a pas d'autres explications
ça peut être l'autre
tu penses
pas le droit d'aller ouais bof non pas
trop tard même moi quand j'ai très envie
de réfléchir au pire je vivais où je
prends sur moi quoi
c'est pas mon avis
chili qui va
pouvoir se lever comme ça je pense ça
peut être que ça
va vraiment y voit un confort de marche
il revient à trop se dit fière jeu est
excellent et rations pardonner
mais ça pourrait expliquer la nullité a
aussi rapide s'il a des problèmes
d'intestins
non mais vraiment à chaque fois les
jambes rigole quand je dis ça mais moi
je regarde à chaque fois les séries
ayant fait
à shawal en raison de passer pour un con
que ça alors que je dire c'est vrai
qu'on le cherche sur les caméras où et
comment tu fais en fait un retour aussi
rapide rapide
pour on n'a pas le droit d'aller aux
toilettes pas sur son temps en fait on
n'a pas de se lever sur son temps quand
ça nous de réfléchir en fait pas le
rapport je sais pas non tu fais pas
pour moi mais pour moi il s'est pas lavé
les mains il va essayer de passer la
bactérie à fada
officer on a le droit de se lever moi
j'ai toujours pensé qu'on en parlera de
se lever sur son cou c'est pas
pour l'heure plus il n'a pas buzzé
d'affaires d'une minute il avait fait un
aller-retour bon
ouais après
je crains que le cas boire ou 4 de café
le café le stress on sent je crois que
ça ça peut un peu déréglé le vote a même
pas besoin du stress en fait ouais mais
beaucoup de café ça dérègle ouais
hein
d'après ces acides c'est pour ça
je sais pas
je pensais pas très loin qui voit cette
huile café par jour je pense que c'est
pas très bon pour la santé il faut se
limiter à deux noms jaillir 3,4 gens
s'aventurent j'ai pas d'idée titien non
plus
c'est dû à quoi le fait de passer son
temps bref je crois que c'est surtout il
ya la triche nomades bas j'avais pensé
aller parler à quelqu'un
le téléphone téléphone c'est comme ça en
tout cas ça se fait pas normalement mais
bon après
voilà c'est que c'est à toi de jeu qui
parler quelqu'un qui te permet le
calibrage 4 je dis ça je dis rien
mais être plus fin tu peux dire
j'attaquerai bien le sillon des 4 way
j'arrive 6
bon après là il va parler à personne
dans la salle des candidats aussi enfin
je rumine n'ya pas de risque imminent
mais
moi je ça m'embêterait joue un coup
c'est mon adversaire je vois ce bar et
heiarii 18 après
je pense gérard l'arbitrage surveiller
le quoi c'est pas normal ce qui s'est
passé ce que tu peux refuser de jouer
l'article 1 3 il est possible uniquement
avec la permission de l'arbitré un
joueur de quitter la salle de jeux un
joueur
à une personne n'étant ni joueur ni
n'est qu'un joueur au très peu se levait
s'il reste dans la zone de jeu mais a
besoin de l'autorisation de leur vie
tous se rendre aux toiles attaque ouais
donc il était allé voir l'arbitré s'est
levé et est allé voir l'armée pour les
dires écouteurs et j'ai mangé j'ai mangé
des huîtres hier soir sur madrid s'était
pas frais ça c'est pas la mer à madrid
ouais il n'y a pas la mer c'est ça il
fait chaud et prime de transport je veux
toi là deux minutes tu reviens et là
alors oui tu dis moi aussi
je me demande si c'est pas l'eau du
robinet de l'hôtel d'ailleurs les
huîtres j'ai entendu un truc jeu parce
que j'aime confirmé l'info qu'il faut
les manger les mois en r ah oui c'est
connu ça à l'ordre ont joint relie des
dépôts ya
même en espagnol il n'y a pas de r
jude lodjou lui aurait fait s'il allait
ou non à la
rsr et c'est
john roth rau new here est oui
son meilleur oui mais même les deux
elles sont bonnes à et non
mais si t'as toléreront lactose aaa
je suis retenu nous faire une blague là
je suis vraiment retenir ouais
là j'étais vraiment pas loin j'ai lutté
contre moi-même sont pas la faire
j'ai quasiment que c'est comme ça
lâche en train de retenir là je te coupe
aux fourgs d'affaires on coupe le micro
avec bordeaux
elle était pas mal quand même chez lui
en fait me retenir jeu pour ce genre
elle était belle très bien
heureusement qu'il ya femme à la régie
elle passait pas à la barre salle a
battu par
donc il a fait f3
avec
et
à
ben époque il parce qu'on disait il doit
trouver le petit fou cette attaque le
cabba a très bien joué
au bond à son gt300 devrait partir
j'imagine
après avoir sifflé faute 6 bravo bus
brown et pau
après ça réjouit sur le fou et fils j'ai
trop hâte est vrai ça c'est bien joué et
franchement impressionnant 6 février 6
aces qui connaît pas assez sur la il a
trop réfléchi non non c'est sûr qu'il
connaît par paul style de la maison
mais franchement si c'est la ligne moi
je suis pas sûr de ce que ça donne alors
d'y abattre le 0 0
pourquoi pas manger une cavale balles
preuve c'est que tu te fais mon genou
tient aussi quoi
et tu vas prendre la tête il aime te
prends intermédiaire s'attaque hui je ne
sais pas et je
prends donc je sais pas dans quel sens
en mai hop mais touche natouri touche la
tour tu fais peut-être g3 maintenant et
il te bouffe maintenant on a par exemple
dit en aparté paradis latin pour moi
donc non donc d'abord tu défends ton cas
les h4 ce qu'il a fait part j'ai trois
est battue la question est en suspens
pour ce qu'elle valait
le coup que les noirs a priori la
théorie de faire c'est de prendre et le
coup dur de l'ordi c'est ça
et tu as peut-être qu'ils aient des six
comme dernière option mais à ce moment
là je pense que les blancs battait pas
mécontente udf 4 tu peux aller dans le
cinq donc des mieux je suis pas à quel
point mais ok plus sympa pour les blancs
quand il s'est relevé n'est pas très
clairement assez des passages toilettes
1 la
suède se devait un peu pour se détendre
ouais s'il a ses habitudes est tout
sauf si ça me paraît quand même dur
dur à jouer
voici qui soulève que par élimination tu
peux avoir non je pense pas parce que
rafa est accueilli procès trois façons
qui
sied pas hideuse et moins bien mais
c'est pas idiot qu'elle construit
après famille joue tempo donc il sait
que son goût des bons ou très mauvaise
derrière francis basset d'attaqué ça
et renforcer le contrôle de 5 notamment
ce que bon genre de variantes comme je
vous disais le plan des blancs a priori
bon outre peut-être les problèmes de
dames eux deux qui vont venir pilonner
les deux fous faire gaffe toujours à ça
mais aussi se fout nrf 4,5 donc si
jamais tu fais fauves 6 alors peut-être
que les mains ils peuvent défendre comme
ça mais non quand tu pars tu as pu les
problèmes sur la colonne le foutu l'a
bloqué ici va pas les lattes cite aussi
doit défendre ça et tu renverses un peu
peut-être l'histoire des initiatives
locales il peut rebondir
tu es peut peut-être songer un coup
comme et quatre non ça joue au tempo en
fêtard donc
ouais donc faux et si ce coup critique
sap est de défendre et de bouffer et
donc tu donnes une pièce on vient d'être
tout à l'heure je puisse trancher en
[ __ ]
je regardais un truc comme ça
prise là bas reese ici est de 10,2 je
sais pas quoi
pour dr robert est
donc là il y aurait deux pions pour la
pièce un fou de cases manche qui peut
devenir assez dangereux
voilà rythme est bon mais il arrive là
enfin ou l'autre là
mais en fait ça se joue au couperet à
cela mais la turbine est tu as un coin 0
0 le deuxième la zone son destin c'est
vraiment ce qu'on pense c'est que ça va
être vraiment dur à faire prier je
serais vraiment surpris qu'ils rentrent
là dedans je suis surpris qu'il a
perdent pas en fait aujourd'hui un
jeu bon écoute ci
pour l'internet tournant c'est pas mal
si fabiano bravo prend bien
c'est une belle première heure de jeu
quoi
complètement si on peut sur le petit
résumé
twitter l'optique express
let's go 1 on part du début ouais
est-ce que c'est l'heure du résumé on
attend deux minutes on attend césar
comme ça les gens qui arrivent à 16h01
on fait ça sur une
once upon a augmenté chez qui on est
prêt je me cherchais un peu d'eau alors
un vincent rouaix vas-y fab
ce qu'il ya des gens qui savent déjà
qu'il ya que le résumé vers 16 heures
donc on va on va attendre
à temps et les deux prochains coups
ouais mais on sait pas ça peut durer
longtemps
j'aimerais trouver un dépôt s'en sortir
web après on veut surtout voir une belle
partie pour le moment c'est du costaud
le h a joué
qu'est ce que ça a joué côté h
serait dommage hb perdre par contre
lors diem pas du tout ce qu'il a fait
mais bon
c'est hyper compliqué
façon nous on est sûr sur les peaux
mais oui si perd aujourd'hui lâche ce
serait malheureux quoi ça annie rey sa
performance d'hier ouais
c'est ça les acquis durant ce tournoi
c'est que tu as beau faire une bonne
partie c'est sur la durée aussi quoi
après la potence à semoutiers bien noir
contreras déjà qui a joué longtemps hier
c'est là plutôt la réussite
mais bon jamais facile hein
il n'a pas encore perdu un
il en aimait mais auxquels s'ajouent
tout cas well une position et s'est un
peu fait rattraper dans l'ouverture
sa prépa excellente avec les blancs un
peu moins avec les noirs je dirais
ouais bah il est plus attendu avec les
noirs en fait c'est bérénice candidats
mme banon bidabe tout le temps tout le
temps au liban même ligne dans
l'italienne le même c'est toujours les
mêmes pour mark lyall animaux pas que
candidat mais ça lui fait qu'il y ait
trop de qui et ses trois façons ce sera
des cinq lois
complexes difficiles un de changer
vraiment tout un répertoire de a à z
avec les blancs et les noirs
cc rend difficiles allait donc on part
pour ce résumé express de la partie
importantissime fab qui oppose fabiano
caruana le dauphin à gan nepomniachi
pour le mont requins du tournoi seul en
tête avec un point d'avancé il faut
absolument que fabiano marque le punto
avec les blancs et ils décident
d'accepter de rentrer dans la petrov
voilà donc on est impatient de voir
qualité il avait pas ce que c'est sûr
que si rendant à petrov c'est pas par
hasard et pas de surprise donc mais
pourrait pas être fou des six le coup
que les jeux qu'on de magnus dans le
match et sur lequel il est très très
préparé rock rock ces quatre attaques le
centre c6 est ici il apparaît pts et le
dame b trop de richard rapporte qui
avait vraiment rien donné il y avait
toujours un coup intéressant en attaque
le cavalier ou quatre qui va être
défendu parfois f5 dame b3 maintenant on
va attaquer bessette il fait dame 17
pour le défendre et cavaliers h4 quasi
nouveautés voilà c'est ça l'idée de
famille c'est de jouer que dans une
partie de moins de 14 ans slovène il ya
déjà longtemps et
et donc il s'en prend aux fouilles 6 il
le recul il vient taper sur le pion ces
quatre dames ces deux ont s'en relève
d'une prise éventuelle qui toucherait la
dame et on touche le cavalier
éventuellement l'option h sept cavaliers
à 6 développe fabre menace cavalli b 4 à
3 on sécurise et la f5 un coup
thématique un de ces petrov moderne
ouais bah faut le faire en fait ce
qu'ils avaient à dire aux 4 b est en
danger en plus si on faisait froid pour
le chasser la chaussette d'arc déjà
signalés et circulent en effet si c'est
toujours peut-être des fous g5 et la vie
pénible donc l'heure où on sécurise bien
ce cavalier mais fabi continue je vais
tempo icaunais il prend des s'éprend des
qualifiés 3 développement il ya
plusieurs options pour les noirs et
dépôts qui choisit tour ses huit coups
logique mais à tort sur la colonne et
famille qui joue f3 bien jouer bonnes
questions aux cavaliers au 4 et c'est
vrai que tu peux pas trop le bouger
peut-être f5 en l'air il a réagiront
faut cette contre attaque le cavalier h4
g3 jouer donc on est encore dans la
préparation de fabiano un qui n'a
réfléchi que huit minutes contre
quasiment une heure pour les peaux qui
vient de répondre femmes pdci sera pas
réglée six donc faux m6 qui était le
coût de la turbine apparemment mais très
compliqué il joue cavalier des six le
coup logique pour protéger le pion f5
mais l'ordinateur semble donner un
avantage aux blancs après un coup comme
dame e21 qui viendraient souligné les
problèmes sur la colonne ne peut être
cavaliers c'est cet avenir mais un jeu
qui paraît beaucoup plus agréable au
blanc fabien way le fou 5e venir la
fille théâtre etc et écoute on va voir
mais petit avantage caruana dans
l'ouverture en tout cas voilà pour pour
se résumer les amis break et 10,6 à
priori adam szoo qu'il prend des sens et
qu'on me dise que l'auteur qui en est un
pion après est ce que tu as envie de le
prendre ou tu peux travailler plus au
corps l'adversaire
termine ce qu'elle donne donne dames 2
cic7 je prends tu es obligé à son
ravisseur
qui essaient 7 qui prend des cinq
clairement en fait y'a pas trop pas trop
autre chose il prend il sait pas de quoi
battre deux fois en fait un tas de choix
non mais c'est à dire un peu ça la
position mais tu pourrais prendre
dufour des cinq dossiers
soient cédés noir qui choisit on a les
deux cas ces paires de fous qui ont de
plus quand même
ouais après s'est installé au centre
c'est pas gagné d'avancé mais tu peux
pas rêver mieux avant la partie que
d'avoir ça une ordonnance à d'apprendre
enfin pas tout à fait mais bon je vais
faire deux paires de fous plus en plus
je répète c'est quand même c'est pas
qu'un pion c'est pas que la paire de
foucauld ac les deux donc même s'il a dû
contre jeu ou quoi mais il doit faire ça
toi sont famille il doit faire parce
qu'en fait sinon toute façon tu as
peut-être du ginkgo qui va t'arriver
dessus que à se ranger doit rien faire
peut-être f4 ça va donner des cases ce
qui est des six pas si mal il peut
revenir vers ses quatre dont tu as
peut-être pas le temps de jouer une
partie en mode lent je m'installe sur
les cadenas nani c'est ok tu vas juste
tu as une bouffée de pions piolenc
d'apple
il est défendu suffisamment il ya quand
même quatre pièces qui le défendent
trois attaquants ce qui passe
17e coup de préparer et à savoir que
dame 2 qui a aidé cinq dames aussi c'est
qu'un la suite très logique donc tu
pourrais sortir à 21,22 coup d'ordi
de ton chapeau
sans forcer ça ça se voit
non mais le foot ils font des gosses
étaient vraiment trop dur et je sais pas
c'est un bon choix en plus la main 4
sympa oui c'est vrai
ouais ce moment-là peut-être prise
friserait vii
ça donne envie aussi damas quatre ans
vrai
d'autres
ouest m 4 tu es tu fais fourrage qui à
13,4
me 2 s'écoule plus logique 1
et hc alireza ce fait un moment qu'on
est pas passé
grand chose à voir partir une partie
comme hier en fait
ça repart fond de court
symétrique
petites manoeuvres
complexes
complexe pas facile a commenté
ding
on m'a dit que je crois qu'il est passé
en mode joue vite je croise trop sa tête
qua
non mais bon si on prend aussi et il y
avait là c'est le coup aujourd'hui mais
bien a priori c'est déjà l'une des
structures adverse et tuvalu prendre
peut-être à 5 enfin j'ai donc
au caire jaqee
qui pose problème à naka en tout cas aux
orages y'a pas moyen raj ouais c'est
beaucoup a dit qu il doit se dire par
moyen de me battre quoi
il n'y a pas moyen radjah
de lâcher dans une bonne position cela a
l'air facile de pousser derrière
qui lâche
à john wayne en mêlée mieux mais bon tu
viennes donné à perdre tous vos supports
un pion tu par défaut bref trois
épreuves qui traîne je sais pas c'est
pas c'est chaud il a réfléchi avant de
faire ça donc il a sa petite idée alors
après probablement que c'est devenu pour
les blancs en fait mais
bon
a déjà fait son tournoi way fait son
tournoi il est un peu en dessous mais
comme fillon comme d'autres vins jeudi
l'est pas il n'est pas il parle pas il
est par sujet quoi mais c'est y pas il
joue c'est parti ben c'est bien de le
voir comme ça ça fait longtemps en fait
même genre qui comme ça voilà ce même
joueur qu'en roumanie quoi
donc c'est cool je promets en norvège
alors un bastion n'était pas le jour sur
non on va dire et c'est ça non violente
est aussi la roumanie qui a déjoué ilya
un an peut-être où je sais plus où tu es
l'effet que dénudées vraiment les blancs
c'était pour sécher le jeu
x 6 dames de aussi possible peut-être
fois et 6 d'abord ouais ça peut tenter
mais mon rêve c'est du joli nom ouais
ben vraie force toute agence 1 c'est sûr
que si tu plantes un bouquet payant le
5e mais peut tu arrives 4c qui va
prendre h4 réuniront le cadre
des tiges et 2
go
ça se regarde oui
oui mais bon bah c'est leur tonton 24 à
jouer sont pas mal ils vont faire foi f6
je sais pas
l'autre c'est quand même le truc à rien
d'en prêter attention plus sain
et d'un de doha et vii bon je sais pas
c'est une sale gueule pas brad heures
je trouve que c'est que tu vas faire
flouer f4 ou prendre ici c'est ap
ça je reviens et qui a valu à trois et
tu va taper c'est à tasser en ta faveur
de garder le fun rapport aux cavaliers
quand même
9 81 ans est bien coupable on s'est
appuyé en liga trop quoi boxer
il faut prendre un certain temps a parlé
tout à l'heure ça donne trop les cases
noires et oui
façon je pense pas pas le temps sur la
veux
je prends de 3,6 ouais
mais
regardez 20 ça c'est juste illustratif
pédagogie prise donc normalement on perd
à cause de ça parce que échec qui en est
avec deux pièces à la fois et que même
sur trois sites ont fait tout reprendre
et 6 mai au quai peu importe disons
qu'on n'est pas dame prend aussi ce
qu'on doive faire sa clé noir doivent
défendre leur fiche pas une l'enlève ce
genre de truc ça va vite s'illustrer
pourquoi c'est si fort pour les blancs
il faut venir là bon je vais rien jouer
noir c'est juste pour montrer la gens
sont des pièces les blancs après ils
vont se décaler le roi
ils vont vous mettre des tours là les
doubler ils vont peut-être blindés la h
5 h 6 l'attaquent trop fait l'option
doublé c'est pas le roi blanc qui est
faible c'est le roi noir donc en gros ce
scénario tu dois venir fait pas trop
limités etc et noir island fait pas tout
à fait tort si tu veux d'autres coups
mais ça changera pas s'il va se passer
donc déploie pour envie de tomber là
dedans
donc franchir ces raisons par cas il l'a
pas fait il le fera pas sauf si tu
penchait fourrage 4 et 4 peut-être
bloquer les gazons
aller fabiano il faut trouver les coûts
maintenant
hommes après écoute il s'est donné le
droit de réfléchir longtemps que la
danse qu'il a prise donc un wayne rooney
a été tourné vers 16 il ya 10 minutes en
gros à
16h01 en fait
magnifique un
petit résumé pour le mettre sur twitter
tu pas si vous avez aimé s'était résumé
sur twitter n'y a pas eu spécialement de
bons retours mais les gens après une
fois qu'ils ont l'habitude d'un truc qui
lie que plus trop ça et qu'ils ont le
diplôme merci ouais c'est ouais c'est ça
après nike + ouais
alors que c'est très très sympa quand
même
tu aimais que sur twitter pas sur le
facebook ou je sais pas ou non que sur
twitter
sur leur père
c'est ensuite s'il fait plus mais vrai
c'est comme avec les analyses de partie
quand même commencé à parler truc rapide
et tous les trucs l'express j'en sais ce
que vous allez arrêter les a et les
analyses longue c'est vraiment très
dommage et enfin huit fois son envie
d'arrêter on arrête enfin je veux faire
plus que des extraits sont réputés
express fait ce qu'on veut en fait
ça qu'il a du coup on s'est doublé le
travail en fait il exprès et violon quoi
ouais mais ça appellera de faire plus
que l'express dans un moment quand les
gens sont habitués on sera très heureux
ce jour là
je pense que pour la greffe je ferai des
express tu les fais avec moi ou pas
d'ailleurs outre aux états unis ces
temps ci c'est quand du 20 au 25 vaches
aux états unis
mais express après
fabriquer leur tout ça à toi en aura
neuf heures de décalage et moi c'est le
matin je pense à l'après midi je vais te
dire à quelle heure c'est à dire c'est
pas compliqué en fait
après si je suis bien installé et où y'a
pas de soucis je suis en voiture en
train de passer pour le tracé la route
qui se pose
là pour parler en fait on en profite on
profite des commentaires en fait pour
discuter les parties sont longues on se
fait notre petit lapin n'est pas en
photo sur manchester je serais heureux
avec son chien
ça qui à l'heure
ils disent trois heures mais trois
heures de kahler en fait
c'est chiant 7 mai à graz à être le même
fuseau horaire que nous non je pense moi
bah ça doit être 19h15 19h30 donc 10h30
pour toi bon j'ai pas si tous les jours
possible mais en soi why not on
discutera de façon
passera des express un
personnage en viendrait presque à
l'oreille catch déjà vu le live
n'importe pas grand chose et métiers pas
vu et que j'ai le temps je préfère
l'analyse longue ah bah oui mr
récap c'est beau
sentant le souffre de favre
après c'est beau tournoi pour la peine
regardez participants zagreb carlson
cheyrou tchané pommiers à chisseaux
mamediarov mvl dominguez vent de forrest
sarich topalov mais bon en vrai quand tu
penses ça descend un peu à la fin mai
karlsson chiroux tchané pause saut
mvm
orapi des blitz est quand même pas loin
de la vérité quoi
ça ritchie fait équipe avec topalov ou
non les deux jours c'est tous
les deux vous passez moi j'aurais pu
avoir un fc sa part of auto pitch to
pitch est allée f c'est au pitch mais
jordan band forest bond sera content de
jouer d'avoir mes dominguez il pas
ridicule non plus on vraiment ça va
ça ne se fait pas je sais pas et nous
pour dominer à ce nom les symboles je
comprends pas tout le line up en fait
très bien moi non plus mais il est beau
je le comprends pas trop non plus mais
bon car la scène si rooney peau sow
mais en fait le truc que je capte pas
pour expliquer c'est qu'il ya des gens
qu'on aime jouer un tournoi toute la
saison c'est comme si en formule 1 td
c'était un grand prix qualys qu as tu la
revoit plus c'est beau non mais avec ta
voiture tu as eu ton d'écurie tiens
c'est une nouvelle écurie pas fait la
saison entière et puis voilà quoi qu'il
arrive pas trop à comprendre qui est
permanent je crois de fil rouge à il est
permanent là dedans en fait vous tous
les autres tournois mais c'est trop
bizarre qu'il est permanent peu
permanente humer que des permanents ou
et une wild card à la rigueur mais voilà
et tu mets le local de l'étape pour lui
faire plaisir à l'arrière comme
mais là ça suffit de pas mal de wild
card que je trouve
[Musique]
pourquoi il ya deux ans je sais pas non
plus voilà
ça arrive je peux comprendre et les
croates mais au fait je crois qu'il aime
bien voir un vieux à chaque fois oui
mais avec rami
oui en fait j'ai pas commander enfin
chaque fois on dit oui ça sert à rien
ces exhibitions il n'ya pas ne sont pas
d'accord en fait mais en fait dans quel
sport tu viens
pour le tennis tu te fais jouer sampras
ton tournoi puis agassi l'année d'après
en fait c'est juste que c'est une
exhibition enfin tu fais pas vrai
tournant avec ces gens là quoi et c'est
tout voilà en fait les voir en
exhibition c'est cool et puis
du coup je
je comprends pas vraiment fait pincer
après 45 fille ruth jaen vld peau ça
fait plaisir
après ils demandent si thomas est prête
à examiner son pote de partout non mais
il a été dûment 1 mondial et c'est un
peu une sorte de légende du jeu un peu
moins quinze ans de métier tu peux les
mettre un peu dans ce genre de rio était
content les voir jouer encore deux ans
entend quoi donc voilà mais
mais en fait ce que je veux dire c'est
si tu fais ton tournoi où tu marques des
points de tournée après tournoi du grand
prix de formule 1 c'est pas pour qu'un
mec qui est semi retraités viennent
jouer un tournoi et puis qui joue plus
les autres et que d'autres mais que tu
es déjà eu balaye joue pas et rejoueront
dans six mois à l'autre c'est bizarre
d'avoir suivi une continuité normal
logique pour moi c'est ce qui fait me
fait dire secondes six tours
basse et de l'exim fins watts n3 que ça
rien en fait ouais ouais c'est de la
merde face la merde ce bourg exige
depuis on le regardera jouer et puis
voilà mais
dommage qu'il manque pas grand chose que
ce soit bien bas à partir de l'an
prochain avec la qualif pour les
candidats bah là je pense qu'ils vont
pas de faire des gaffes permanent et
d'autres vont venir jouer pour pas se
qualifier quoi
je comprends plus rien mais a
en tout cas sera à ce train-là
spécifiquement sera sympa mais celui-là
toute la torah de belles parties selon
matti karlsson qui dépote et maxime
virot déjà donc nous on a nos joueurs
face à desjardins yves tassot qui est là
dans une gaze cycliques tam année
et puis non pas même les guest injures
topalov ou quoi après il n'y a rien
d'infamant à 6 soit là c'est juste du
temps là la construction de leur saison
que ça me dérange en fait nous
et vende forez on verra peut être
dangereux on se souvient qu'il a gagné à
tata steel quand même jusqu'à 10 il est
tout le monde à mes torts et la forêt
wild card ce serait bien quoi tu me dois
de garde forêt sur dix joueurs oui bah
je suis méfiant sur sa riche du couvent
au milieu local de l'étape ça fait 3
valcartier religieux à ses 30% du dfi
c'est beaucoup car c'est beaucoup et
dans un grand châle tend à croître de 4
sur les 128 où on a plus tôt et vite
peut-être à 256 joueurs en revanche la
non
c'est pas quand tu commences non pas des
mecs qui jouent pas le premier sou vent
qui sont
allés khalifa les wild cards talent
immense et je me suis perdu
samedi je sais pas huit wild card ok ça
fait une
c - de une tous les dix ans en tout cas
non mais trois trois wild cards pour
d'ivoire c'est trop oui une c'est bien
environ 10 sur 128 10 donc oui c'est un
petit un petit quota quoi donc là tu
comprendras sur les 10
points tout le cese ok c'est pas un
fainéant 21 mondial au même ce qui joue
plus et
surtout un rapide 1,8 à ses cadences
s'est passé cadence il était mieux en
partie landes toute sa carrière
mais bon voilà bobo tournoi je le
suivrai
chouette jerry capitan
on va encore plus pour 10 litres des
rapides baisse était rapide donc c'est
bien l'express du repas deux buts après
ouais enfin oui c'est rapide et blitz
de montréal c'est bien parce qu en fait
ouais tu ça près ce qui se passe dans la
journée qui a fait quoi la course le
classement cumulé
ont fabriqué réfléchit
ça fait un moment il avait
que 15 minutes sur le court 11 1 puis en
plus ce récap l'ont mise à part des
partis on a déjà fait sur des parties de
rapide assez exceptionnel mais c'est
rarissime eric à plomb sur du rapide
sans fin au final le récap dure autant
de temps que la partie s'est un peu
enfin
le daily mail heures et quatre minutes
et sur twitter si vous avez raté
l'ouverture n'hésitez pas à le like
ainsi si vous aimez ça que les gens là
et que plus des photos à la con tu
prends une photo de mix michas a fait
recette
tiens je peux issue peut tenter vous il
ya le récap se mettre une une photo de
niche à qui on verra qui viennent qui on
verra qui gagne allez let's go mais en
fait je comprends c'est même moins fait
des fois je veux des vidéos de sur
twitter j'ai la flemme des vidéos enfin
juste un chien je suis très heureux
quand tu appartiens prolite
bas je tente
mischa pendant les candidats
on va voir qui a le plus de like
didier moi non je ne serai pas à villard
de lans parce que ça commence déjà à van
avant la fin du candidat
donc moi je vais compter jusqu'au bout
enfin j'espère et
donc voilà en fait je jouerai pas de
toit de l'été bat angers faire une vraie
photo ja prendre maintenant parce qu'on
dise c'est une ancienne quoi
qu'est-ce qui nous prouvent pas bien
pris une photo de maintenant
[Musique]
la photo avoir lieu on va voir vos
marques qui gagne je vais mettre mon
like aussi
et bien sûr je mettrais un live sur me
choque
beaucoup mieux
qu'elle adore sa position mais au repos
solucom ses tweets et s'était
immédiatement
elle vraiment très heureuse
on va voir c'est plus intéressant micha
pas les candidats ou les candidats eux
mêmes déjà 35 like en trente secondes
c'est en fait de faire un live vous qui
me choque on regardait m'échappant les
candidats quoi
6e plus belle julia stone tu
sais pas quand on prononce enfin l'aïe
qu'est ce que vous préférez
demi ça
c'est bon colère très heureusement nobel
est parfait très bien il tire un peu la
langue non non un peu
encore vador amplement de ta merde
creton de commande t ta merde
mais c'est un massacre ah ben oui oui
bah oui dire que le résumé jean ligne
depuis plusieurs minutes il a 80 nike
michel chassang 85 like en ligne alors
que c'est la partie phare des candidats
je te rappelle non mais c'est vraiment
passionnant ce tournoi
sur cette plaque
pourquoi analyser des parties d'échecs
alors tu peux mettre une petite chérie
mais romain qu'un pas qui me l'a envoyé
en photo si ce matin est bien présent
du coup les récap express s'arrête
michard way gollnisch a
bientôt on top tweets
frevo michard au tt quoi me jean top
trends
demandera de faire animer un string
peut-être fait la posant le fauteuil tu
me santi micro
je vous fais défiler des trucs sur
l'écran il faut à tout prix me regarde
on s'en fout elle dort je sais pas
très pratique jeu petit récap c'est
terrible de dh qui trollent micha la
plus belle les autres à la poubelle
désormais tous les jours à 16h une photo
denis charlet
il arrive que tu vas faire une partie à
l'aveuglent du début à la fin on
beaucoup trop dur ça je laisse ça aux
professionnels c'est dur ça il faut voir
les pièces j'ai la tête et tout trop
complexe enfin non plus tu y arrives pas
non trop dur
on y arrive tout ça
on rêve tous depuis longtemps
je suis devenu odieux olympique et
chaque balle j'ai même joué quand
j'étais petit
95 à 99 peut-être un truc comme ça où 94
chez plus
notre âge avez vous pas vu le début je
reste pas longtemps mais ça permet de
raccrocher les wagons le temps de la
pause ah bah oui les wagons sont
raccrochés
non mais c'est comme motif pour partir
du coup est ce que tu aimes bien les
vidéos extraits ce matin et amoureux ses
vidéos extraits ce synthé gérer un petit
voir le train qui se raccorde quoi ce
qu'on peut lancer le tgv c'est beau en
fait fall qui est en vacances aux etats
unis comme je dois vraiment faire leur
éclat express
309 lie 416 obama et micha bien devant
dans le dos et si évident bas c'est une
combinaison tactique en fait qui assez
facile mais évident enfin sa logique
hein tu t'en lève de son vis-à-vis tu
viens te mettre sur cette colonne et tu
vois que les fous bouge pas d'attaquer
les deux on vient après évidence et à
pâques il prend des cinq bons s'il n'a
pas de lapin
je sais pas à quel point c'est fort
cela dit oui bon tu peux avec ça mais
peut-être que le faire pareil quand à
l'aide annoncée deux jours ça mais
oui en fait si t'as pas si t'as pas
qu'il prendrait 5 ne te fais pas de
besoin mais en fait c'est est il là quoi
je pensais pas le problème c'est qu'il
doit calculer les finales
mais est-ce que ça yanis que parce que
là tu avoues parlant d'âge positionnelle
quoi
d'amaga dont on n'a pas regardé juge ce
que j'ai cru peut-être c'est quoi ces x
f406 en seconde nous a dit que phil
rogers était peut-être bien
je voulais juste refaire un petit tour
francis troy
waouh assez complexe aussi
ding
ding ceignac un peu
je rends le bonjour alors il va 10,69
el hiba banny 69 valises à ièrement
alibaba a ses vertus logique mais
philippe tête il a fait une petite
italie bat donc alibaba sur un crime
qu'il est très heureux en fait de deux
méchants de caruana
il doit être pour caruana plutôt parce
que l'américain je crois qu'il est très
heureux du quadrillage
4g dit quoi j'ai perdu sont
les michelin qui sera contre
mitchell et ce n'est pas du l2 pidoux
c'est beaucoup quoi elle en bobine aussi
qu'en maintenant un petit peu
en ce moment baisse la ration de
croquettes
moi j'adore ce même
si j'avais déjà vu non
et
j'adore ce même voici et
enfin ce que tu reconnais bien là tel
nom ouais j'aime bien tout calculé m je
suis beaucoup plus fort que toi
bon on va attendre un fabien nom qui va
devoir jouer là au moment donné
je t'avais 2
réfléchi
façon qu'ils étaient dans des attitudes
un peu de bouger
[Musique]
si magnus même veine jouent avec leur
niveau de blitz en particulier dans
lesquels niveau selon je crois qu'on
enlève 300 points d'après ce que j'ai lu
basse et maxime queste aux théories mais
je crois que c'est pas que maxime a oui
moi je les lui autre part
donc je ne sais pas
dans les 2005 je sais pas jusqu'où ça
marche ce truc
là ça marche à tout niveau
non je pense pas assez pour l'effort
après ça
m'a tué jeudi que damas quatre et
d'adama cadre aux caisses est fort mais
je sais pas moi je qu'est ce que je
disais faut prendre quatre je comprends
efficace très bon mais jamais je perds
ça
ok c'est nul
je sais pas si bons jours de ça en fait
cette région qui ne te passer le bonjour
dans la passe le bonjour à tout le monde
du coup
damas cade du cou qui est intéressant
et ça regrette on n'a pas envie de ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure ça devrait
bouger proposait c'était ça on refuse
sont pas trop mais c'est vrai qu'on va
se prendre prend 1,6 et puis apprendre à
la casse pour le cavalier ça a tapé là
ça a tapé là et les problèmes donc ok je
pense qu'on n'a pas trop envie mais si
on peut pas fabriquer fiat 5 à 7 7 jours
c'est 6 mai j'avais une position un peu
acrobatique du coup
un peu moche peut désorganiser un peu
pas terrible
prend 1,6
il faut prend 1,4
g prend tout reprend
bouffe et cette finale là bas vous fait
des 5
pouces et issiaka
[Musique]
priori faisons jouer là dessus
lectoure des six qui arrive si jamais on
défend
ok mais sinon juste se mettre en place
ce croc avons d'autres tu as tout à
l'heure je t'aime bien ça
ouais c'est un bon plan on a aussi le
plan d'échangé de fronde le cavalier au
cas où je veux cahiers contenant des
fous comme d'odanak ah ouais ça ça me
parle comme comme pression
ok c'est vrai que c'est un choix
cornélien puisque ça a l'air intéressant
et dames 2 c'est ce qu'on disait un
sagan iab sion mais
moi je trouve que je prends enfin je
pense que je prendrais plutôt d'un menu
puisque c'est un moins de leurs
avantages de live quoi
dans me2 t sur
damas quatre
témoins surnom
bah tu es sûr que tu es rien pions avec
dams est ici mais après c'était surtout
une finale il a fait dans la 4
comme quoi
bas donc a priori c'est un bon coup
comme mathieu nous a dit
ok
je vais tomber à l'autre 1/2
cinquante là on a juste regarder a
brièvement la pression qu'on obtenait ce
je peux comprendre le choix s'appelle un
bête
ça même l'air assez logique fab
si on est parti pour dire fab un tel
taux d'image
c'est terrible fab
jean va le faire chier fab
bon moi j'ai 0,70 sa profondeur 32 ans
ce qui est pas mal hein et va en gros
scam
pour ces six commises enfin au but mais
bon ça se comprend
seul coup
mais oui c'est normal en fait baby qui
repasse derrière
c'est une belle partie pour le moment
une heure et demie de jeu
c'est beau
sa clique
sa clique sa clique
vicat et moi je repars à demain à bassa
on sait un petit plage
l elysée a trop perdu
pour
pour que l'oubli grèce 1
avec sa paire ludwig parent
dès que ça perd on le perd aussi
voilà on donc j'ai 5 mais le problème
c'est que d'un procès d'emprunt soit
c'est une menace quand même des changes
les dames se fout il recule et l'autre
là bas donc faux c'est ça le problème
s'il ya une vraie menace des blancs
face eu un
week-end bien fait qui fait bien une
grosse demi heure de réflexion sur le
coup
ouais après dur à dire on vient de voir
de la casse pourrait se passer dams donc
la ligne sur laquelle il a hésité
c'était ça je sais pas de quoi tu n'as
reprennent du cavalier du fou mais en
fait il ya du passé un bon temps à
regarder ça et c'est direct je suis
bloqué jav pas avancer trop
on serait un truc comme ça
mais ces histoires de jugement je peux
pas trop vous dire les deux
ce2 s'entendent et donc il n'a pas
choisi de gagner un pion comme ça il a
choisi damas quatre et a priori ce qu'on
attendait noir sur fuselées changé d'âme
avec la tour
que les blancs prennent alors sur un
coup comme pion prend sa paire du
matériel illico presto parce qu'une
déviation de cette dame
donc il peut pas et si prendre la tour
on échange la dame est une fois deux
fois cette emprise donc obligatoire
d'aller prendre là bas on reprend ils
reprennent de la tour du pin c'est la
même histoire avec tour francis a priori
on joue la finale et
voilà alors est-ce qu'on fait faux et
quatre fers en f2 ce que ça mais après
évidemment les noirs vont essayer de se
battre et qui est bessin et cooke et c4
du coup comme ça mais ces avantages
blanc est ce que il ya deux plans
possibles ces soirées avec le bon fou
ici h5 laura monte pression ici août
être un touriste est d'abord force est
d'abord avec le fou qui vient taper la
deuxième plan c'est de prendre tout
simplement et de jouer le bon rapport
matériel qui a veillé contre le mauvais
faut donc plus agréable pour les blancs
et donc on devrait avoir tout à cette
position là normalement sur l'échiquier
d'ici quelques minutes
bah quoi d'autre n'est pas juste trompé
faire de la merde va faire torse et 6
à 6 g patour c6 je pense qu'un potentiel
de faire de la merci
ok peut-être
du coup il serait mal mais je pense que
c'est possible qu'il fasse de la merde
qui joue vite et mal ouais je sais pas
exactement pourquoi et comment mais mon
avis c'est possible
ça va bien finir par faire de la merde
un moment donné dans ce train n'est pas
fou ou alors il a bien changé
j'ai du mal à y croire
du reste moins d'une heure en tout cas
mais là c'est sûr qu'il est ne plus y
ont pas super agréable et une défense
voir défendre pendant un moment quoi
24la on nous demande
aux
les chansons échange les dames c'est la
même que tu as leur empire non
hilton en a parlé de ce problème lataste
y ont attaqué la nôtre qui débarque en
fait les blanches france ils sont plus
contents d'en regarder la paire de fou
que avoir échangé là bas ce que la
structure comme ça ok elle est pas belle
mais en soit on va pas gagner de science
pas faible et donne même une colonne de
contrôle jaunards je sais pas où en est
donc t'as pas les blancs tu vois c'est à
eux de jouer là il va pas faire faux bon
cavalier donc au moins dans l'autre cas
de figure tu les impose un peu à faire
ça
après tours se situe peut-être jouer
différemment avec les blancs mais ça a
l'air d'être licou quoi
ça peut être aujourd'hui qui permet pas
je t'annonce bas c'est très bien pour
l'intérêt du journal
je serai pas une défaite
n'importe quoi c'est une caruana qui
vient la chercher
ouais
à recife série donc c'est pas le coup
c'est pas le coup alors confus j'y
pensais je les dames 17 sous des caftans
des cats échec je me demandais pourquoi
ça marchait pas en fait mais peut-être
fait dame 17 rue des quatre jets d'oeuf
ou 17 km et 5
et que
déjà tu menaces que ie 7
sur dame prend du coup on va dire fou
prend des quatre échecs intérieurs aux
g2g de
17,17 qu à l epr en dessin qu'on peut
avoir la position dans un ordre ou dans
l'autre et que
tanguay et bien il va faire des
caudillos 7 est attaqué qu'est ce que tu
fais preuve quatre d'abord la truffe
quatre ans premier
tech le quai des six
ouais ça sent pas bon pour les peaux
écoute c'est la vente que donne la
turbine
est fermé bref si seeded m17 vous 17
rebonds c'est pareil en fait qui est des
cinq coups des quatre
ouvrages et de son regard des pour ses
huit médailles on est dix fois fiat
requis un bon coup que peut-être le
meilleur coup d'envoi le messager chien
si j'étais avec kallos est aussi de voir
qu'elle est plus précis mais il faut
être quatre ça la force et le coup on
avait naturellement
je fais monter à 30 de profondeur à
celle
là se monter
bon après c'est pas gagné d'avancé
c'est pas terminé encore un mais
écoute les deux j'aime bien c'est un 42
points 41
donc c'est peut-être là des
transpositions qui avait lieu cette 3ème
set il faut faire il dit fouet 6,4 à ce
moment là
parce qu'elle a tellement fort titou
recettes food et si c'était très bien
l'attak un coup sûr fleuve 4es et
5es de sortir tranquille où ton fond f1
la meilleure défense et de très loin ses
quilles civic ainsi que des coupes
simples maintenant une prophétie quatre
échecs au quai ses katas pour les noirs
en fait je sais pas pourquoi c'est que
1,30 mais ça a l'air d'être un bon en
fait ouais et
d5 et merci au revoir comme une
intrusion aussi certes on prend
famille valet là dedans
ça pourrait être terminée très vite en
fait cette partie et ça pourrait
remettre tout le monde à égalité enfin
tout le monde en tout cas ces deux là et
sa relance complètement naka on peut
aller voir où il en est même peut-être
juste avant de voir si famille trouve la
ligne mais je pense que
c'est que des poèmes pas défendre [ __ ]
pas son truc l'initiative est très très
bien
défendre les positions un peu
désagréable
c'est beaucoup moins ça cheuvreux qui se
colle en saphir où il restera quand même
un peu là ya pas de relance fait enfin
je veux pas vous mentir
tu peux mentir il aa - 2 obtient il a
moins uns et les autres à plus 3 enfin
un gouffre deux points c'est trop
surtout constaté un leader avec deux
points et qui craque mais si mal est
donné oui mais ça sera derrière quand
même quoi
balle et s'ils gagnent les six dernières
parties peut encore gagner un bon ça sur
le sujet
mais vaut mieux gagner toute façon
il ya trop d'égards
ça semble dur un pourri carreau
pas perdre encore mais c'est un vrai
pion de moi
freineront c'est le stolt à damas trois
kayakistes avec machin tu étudies d un
maquillage 5e 5
tu es là tu as besoin de ses coûts
et
ouais ce mot juste pour art fair use du
coup sûr ça donne parce que c'est yann
c'est cool pour lui un
bon il avait failli 4 ce qui est pas mal
après
bon ok c'est plus animées car j'ai mal
juger je pensait s'être vraiment des
manoeuvres un truc c'est plus jeune il a
faim il a fait f4 il veut faire
peut-être est-ce projet 5 wef s'est
confirmé ce coup g4 donc il a des
petites idées
plus animées car appui pour revenir sur
la porte quand même revenir à la
quatrième place oui ça je sais
et ding ding arrive à pousser un peu où
justine et change tout oui je vous dis
non à ces gars là a priori mais
il fait que des particules chargées en
ligne oui te fais un micro truqués puis
peut-être
si tu défends mais à un moment il te
veux
rester sur la partie de jours on va des
deux acharnés
les deux bourreaux mischa qui est venu
un qui arrivait dans le renfort le
bureau de renforts bienvenus
je pense que notre soleil et la chose
et là du coup elle trouve l'endroit un
peu fred
de la maison
tu peu après ils font ça les chiens des
rangs canicule qui fasse chaud pas
choper il adore se mettre au soleil à
prison super chaux neuve pour bronzer
quand ils
ont tous ça il adore le soleil
famille qui va probablement trouvé le
coup 1
peu de vitamine d je sais pas si les
chansons la vitamine d avec le soleil
robe à leur métabolisme en fait
lens a su côté micha
bas ils font tous sa
jolie ces petits animaux
là c'est ce que dit il vole ou deux au
bronzage égale plus de live sur twitter
je suis pas sûr que ce soit vrai pour
les chiens
fabiano
qui va aller chercher le coup
rien ne transpire pas vrai ça je savais
un peu par la truffe non non on parle la
langue
ils issus de la langue
chaque fois que j'entends pas une niche
à l'invention que get your kevin mais
c'était à chaud
c'est ça chars et
d'ailleurs
ça c'est alexandre ou alexandra et
devrait les deux marchent
que me chasser comme israël
ou boris tout cas ceux qui savent mais
le soleil favorise le calcium et le
phosphore c'est bon pour les os des
animaux c'est pour cela qu'ils vont
naturellement au soleil dont toujours
seul en subirait
des chiens afin d'island records dans la
transformation de la langue voilà ça
peut être super efficace non plus quoi
je me souviens que ces petits en voiture
je
suis à fond dedans je me peuvent être
sucre
s'est endormi
c'est beau la vie des chiens quand même
très rassurant aussi
bon dans une bonne famille tout aussi
vrai aussi tu peux vraiment une vie
heureuse
on a plus qu'à attendre le coup là on a
un peu fait le tour de ce qui pouvait
arriver
un truc est parti voir un beau fightway
mince affaire se bat c'est le fait même
le montage des candidats c'est que ça
joue en fait beaucoup plus ou moins pour
partie du jeu d'échecs mais
j'avais toujours des combats et c'est
pas mal
oui alors qu'ils seraient pas obligées
ceux qui sont déjà battus entre
guillemets mais ils ont pas envie de
finir dernier remontée quoi
myers a pu encore largement finir
troisième fait bizarrement oui
non mais en fait et puis vu que
l'éventualité que peut-être quinzaine ne
jouerait pas tu peux te dire allez donc
la deuxième place et peut être à portée
de fusil
papa et ses feintes un micro espoirs ça
puisse avoir quelque chose en deuxième
ça rien c'est que vous faire venir
dernier mais n'a peut-être pas cette
année vous peut-être que si je
préférerais que si moh d'ailleurs mais
bon c'est pas quoi
aller la jeune dame prend 17 ça c'était
sûr
que pensez vous des déclarations de
cramique sur le niveau de jeu de ce
tournoi bah moi je trouve qu'il exagère
et un crâne nick wey surtout qu'il
entraîne un joueur qui est dernier donc
non mais en fait gers ils étaient pas
parties prenantes dur truc ce sera ce
serait déjà une chose mais là en plus il
est coach d'un des joueurs
et se jouera lors plus se trouve qu'il
est dernier donc dire que c'est le pire
candidat
tu critiques ton travail quoi
jason shawa cram ning dit que c'est de
la merde jamais le jeu en fait
c'est peut-être ce que c'est un tournoi
qu'il n'a jamais gagné
en boîte je disais n'inversons
s'est jamais qualifié
en d4 non vendus au coût prochain ça
changerait en fait
non mais cramique on veut prendre son
avion considération c'est pas le
problème c est un des grands joueurs
mais
je sais pas où chaque fois que j'entends
des gens tant eddy se joue mal on a
tendance à vous bien vague sabu pas
jouer ou se défouler et et 2 de la série
qui devait pas
jarre dire que la partie à ferroudja
rapportent ils ont là 2003 c'est juste
faux en fait ils ont joué à 2002 qui
viennent
donc shebad et il veut faire un peu le
buzz avec des phrases si je ne sais pas
moi en fait
ils sont pas si mal ses candidats il est
aigri
bonjour saint ouen où il est très sévère
mais
je rappelle l'ufc pas cnic ouais ouais
on sera pas loin de ce dernier tournant
il est un demi sur les huit indiens sur
18 est terrible
après c'est dur les boulistes contre des
joueurs comme ça quand tu es quand la
retraitée victoire du coup vous oui mais
bon
comme on craint dictée champion du monde
qui n'a jamais gagné les candidats eh
ben
raul castro qui a défié extrait du chi
jours
s'il a perdu la finale les candidats
compteraient shirov 2 0 dans un match
qui s'est joué je crois en espagne à
l'époque
du coup chirac doit être finaliste et
puis basta
et je sais pas pourquoi kasparov l'a pas
vu
soi-disant me savais pas d'intérêt mais
normalement t'es shooter contours des
champions d'avoir un mec une pro facile
si l'on parle attirer les sponsors
tchassa rien fait c'est pas le fond du
fond du truc mais un truc à kasparov a
imposé que soit kramnik cet écrin unique
élu avec aurait dû refuser d'ailleurs
c'était un vrai un dur
ouais bon j'avais perdu le match refus
de faim oui mais si je des retards une
considération pour ton sport tu refuses
normalement explorer que si je suis
qualifié ces girafes ou sait rien et
puis tant pis
même en avoir une grosse way
peut-être pas le cas
pourtant il est grand
non mais vous
pourrez dire un
que après l'été là et puis bah il a tapé
caspar un fils ait conservé le titre
honte l'écho puis il a perdu un jour ils
à conserver contre acheter contre neutre
topalov et puis en 2007 il a perdu
contre 2008 chez plus la bonne un contre
un en quoi
ces deux minutes après les faits il se
qualifie et le 2013 avait fait un bon
candidat mais failli c'est failli c'est
pas gagné
mais disons bon ok je vais pas remettre
en cause ce qui était dur ou quoi mais
ses déclarations sont à prendre je sais
pas voir avec des pincettes
noms propres amis que de changer non pas
du tout maintenant il a juste perdu
times square
il est pas bien joué
elle aurait pas eu ce fils de procédure
il aurait peut-être jamais été champion
du monde ou peut-être il aurais tu aimé
on sait pas quoi penser j'avais le
niveau pour ans mais bon prix il y en a
eu d'autres
une entrée qui cramique bassirou déjà
shirov il a rien dit je salue un peu
détruit sa carrière en fait
un peu dégueu
pas qu'ils aient un peu de sièges c'est
à dire c'est que tu faisais toujours
pire est du monde on dirait en fait non
car pas kasparov après c'est pas le mec
le plus gentil de l'histoire de
l'humanité quand
même des déclarations par un bep spécial
un grand joueur d'échecs et sppf
peut-être le plus grand ou top 3 enfin
bon peu importe assez subjectif mais le
talent l'homme à côté ou quoi c'est une
autre histoire ça c'est particulier il
ya des trucs qui l'a dit franchement
on sa vie
qui font un peu flipper
et bouffe nous étions des cinq familles
il faut différencier la moindre aide
c'est important
pire que carrier qui n'auraient karekin
puissance voilà la ccara keynes et
c'est un enfant d'un enfant de choeur à
côté là c'est on en n'est plus du tout
au même niveau là c'est
des trucs ou d'un moment tu te demandes
s'il voit pas les gens comme des pions
sur un échiquier c'est d'une gravité
parfois
quand même assez hallucinante quand même
ils sont capables de lire des trucs
c'est
c'est terrible
on connaît aucun sens j'adore le joueur
avec fois le joueur préféré mais après
on différencie le joueur de l'homme quoi
enfin peu importe à onfray vos
recherches que vous voulez
et vous trouverez si vous cherchez bien
donc à cette position bon on attend
qu'elle prendrait 5 de famille on espère
qu'il va le faire ceci fait un timide
coup comme fou ou trois je crois qu'ils
perdraient parle de son avantage
non mais il va le faire c'est sûr
oui ok c'est hyper logique on bouffe est
un pion il va se manger là dessus on
bouge le roi et les noirs doivent gérer
une fourchette à venir donc bon bah tu
fais ça et puis bon on avait dit que ça
c'était pas mal on revient là alors s'il
va là bas je crois que c'est pire à ses
pires mais je pense que j'aligne
je sais plus ce qui se passe les
normands circulaire c'est une sale
tronche façon parvis de m as est plutôt
problème c'est qu'à ce coup là malgré
tout et on n'a pas trop le temps de
s'amuser à prendre ça parce que dans
cette variante
bon resto recettes on a stoppé aussi
donc on gagne un pion à priori à fausser
cadre aussi qui arrivent après il ya
peut-être lui je sais pas ce que c'est
si nettes net ce
peut-être moins nette
bon on est même manière des nations
faire tomber mais bon
pas évidente
on peut avoir une finale
tu peux reposer les cavaliers sont là
ça pousse pas sûr qu'ils soient gagnants
mais ça pousse car il y aurait si c'est
quand même sacrément mal ouais elles
vont peut-être pas moyen de chasser lui
de revenir
au boulot tu vois c'est qu'on sépare ça
d'abord
du coup ça maintenant il faut trouver
pour couvrir la case
et ça reste pas super agréable parce que
évidemment on peut peut-être prendre là
haut il va prendre du fou de la tour
prendre ça
donc plus aussi peut-être mieux cela en
fait
il doit être plus sympas transformer
bout ça va
mais c'est juste la tête des cavaliers
en fait la différence les cavaliers
blanc et camionneurs
ok famille qui va jouer il a pris des 5
on avait la cam il l'a fait bravo en d4
ses forces et après peut-être que un
kung-fu 3 qu'on n'a pas regardé jouer à
main dans la main on aura je dois leur
logique mais
c'est comme dépôt une petite pause qui
pause s'impose pour fab j'avais mangé un
peu de saint-aigulin après un tir une
tape aux bruits et la barrière à cuisine
autant ouais normalement donc roigé de
dépôt qui a joui se relever
instantanément va profiter de l'absence
de femmes pour faire un petit tour
dingli rennes contre contre duda c'est
la partie où il se passait pas grand
chose même si tout ça va peut-être digne
et rennes à peut-être essayer de de la
jouer mais tout ça a l'air d'être d'être
solide aujourd'hui donc on va aller
filer vers les partis qui nous intéresse
plus en réalité hikaru nakamura contre
radjabov il est un pion de moins à
carreaux et les blancs vont pouvoir
commencer à jouer b4 et on voyait leur
majorité à la dame avec un pion passé à
qui a l'air très puissant ici sur sur
les dames et les noirs qui ont peut-être
du mal installé cavalière 4 damas choix
puisque le cavalier se fera prendre
instantanément par le fou donc sur b4 il
essaiera peut-être de jouer avec des f 5
1 pour ouvrir éventuellement la colonne
f mais peut-être que ce serait un petit
peu prématurée parce que pour le moment
il y aura un damas 2 1 qui viendraient
cloud et la dame et forcer les changes
qui ce qui permettrait aux blancs de
rentrer dans une finale
complètement gagnante avec ce pion à
beaucoup trop fort donc
cavalli h 5 b 4-1 pour protéger le
cavalier prendre de l'espace et avoir dû
damas deux semblent très fort avantage
pour le moment à timour mais hikaru a
plus d'un tour dans son sac excellent
défenseur on le sait et il s'est passé
quelques petits trucs dans la partie
d'alireza après f4 à 4 pouces et deux
baies 5 puis on prend on comprend qu'il
va les prendre il a donné temporairement
une pièce mais pour la récupérer après
des cadres donc ils se retrouvent avec
un pion de moins mais
avantage pas vraiment de développement
mais en fait après e5 le roi reste au
centre qu'on a tout de suite les fous
qui tape sur le rock on à la tour qui
peut arriver éventuellement en
f4 et peut aussi avoir un coup ici comme
fou des deux pour aller chercher fou c3
est allé toucher le cavalier il
semblerait qu ali reza une très belle
position ici qui lui convient en plus
une position dans son style et on
pourrait imaginer
une victoire d'ali reza aujourd'hui en
tout cas pour le moment il est mieux et
il pourrait revenir à la quatrième place
dans ce tournoi en milieu de tableau et
pourquoi pas viser un podium aux
candidats s'il réussit à se réveiller et
a montré son vrai visage dans ce
tournant en tout cas les réserves qui
montre qu'il est résistant il a joué une
partie très longue et fière et réussit
aujourd'hui encore
à être à 100% dans sa partie et à mettre
la pression sur son adversaire
allez on va retourner maintenant sur la
partie qui nous intéresse le plus
aujourd'hui le duel du leader grand
favori maintenant du tournoi iliad
nepomniachi qu'il ya un point complet d'
avance sur son poursuivant
seul dans le groupe caruana le groupe du
deuxième donc tout seul
à la deuxième place et qui doit
absolument battre nepomniachi pour
ramener un petit peu tout le peloton sur
sur le joueur russe hélas après roy g2
ils semblent avoir une très très belle
position ils menacent un ici donc
c'était un échec donc il est obligé de
bouger le roi mais ils menacent un ici
cavaliers cet échec fourchette et on a
vu pas mal de variantes avec fab après
tour 8 le fou pourrait venir en aide
quatre cavaliers ces cinq peut-être
cavaliers cet échec 3f cet effet fin et
la position des pièces noir semble
problématique on pourrait voir une tour
arrivé en d1 fou peut-être venir verser
4 et une position qui tient déjà sur un
fil très mince très menue pour pour yann
nepomniachi le joueur russe il faut qu
elle il faudrait peut-être un miracle a
maintenant aujourd'hui pour la tenir il
doit y avoir bien du 75 80 % de chances
de gain pour le joueur américain
américano italien même
fabiano caruana
entrain peut-être de se racheter de sa
défaite d'hier cinglante contre le
streamer joueurs américains hikaru
nakamura qui lui pour le moment est en
difficulté 1 contre radjabov et qui
pourraient s'y perd aujourd'hui ne pas
profiter de sa superbe partie d'hier est
restés malheureusement à un point et
demi derrière les deux leaders les deux
co leaders en cas de victoire de fabiano
il n'y a pas de départage particulier
dans dans ce tournoi en cas d'égalité ça
se jouera dans un départage en partie
rapide fabien et et on sait que
nepomniachi est très bon dans cet
exercice mme avec beaucoup d'enjeu les
niveaux peuvent se niveler et fabiano a
déjà aussi prouvé qu'en rapide il avait
son mot à dire ouais non se passe à
cadence fétiche mais il atteindrait 7 4
ans est donc
assuré de la gestion des nerfs en fait
un tel truc oui des prépas aussi parce
que c'est rare d'envoyer les prépas mais
une rapide mais là ce sera l'occasion de
jouer mail voire même très mail voire
même bac email
en tout cas je pense que fabiano et
grand favori en menant dans cette partie
oui je jouais tout la position celle way
for a bien calculé parce que on a vu
pire défaut de proposer des fois
on organise la belle position
franchement
c'est quand même dingue gagne
aujourd'hui ce sera une grosse preuve
d'un mental absolument exceptionnel
c'est pas un tel comme les peaux qui
aurait pu faire ça et c'est pas faux
dur à dire en fait mais oui le montant
exceptionnel c'est sûr après dépôt ou
s'écrouler mais
même avec une défaite aujourd'hui moi je
suis pas sûr qu'il va s'écrouler il
tourne bien en course
la réaction quand même en est à sa peau
n'est
la réaction d'orgueil un quelque part
avec son orgueil non on peut dire
on peut tout à fait le dire
du joueur américain mais d'origine
italienne
faut-il le rappeler de la qui tire toute
sa puissance en fait c'est possible que
ça vienne de là
ça ne m'étonnerait pas
ça ne m'étonnerait pas fab
est vrai pas le problème pour les noirs
c'est ces pièces
nombreuses à ne pas être défendue sur la
colonne des balles sont rois de fou le
fou le cavalier l'eau de là bas à
l'ouest les blancs qui vont chercher un
une tour là qui peut mettre le font avec
à gagner un temps qui me suis dit
fourchette ce fut un peu exposé le roi
qui peut être tout chat blanc cette
diagonale donc il ya beaucoup de petits
détails qui font que sur le recul et
c'est clair avantage pour les blancs
c'est une accumulation de petits détails
qui font une grande différence
il est allé en deux grands joueurs
d'échecs en ce moment bien caruana
s'accapare avis bon plus ils ont des
bons joueurs de tennis a progressé aux
échecs non c'est là au début des années
2000 les tournois internationaux
c'est à dire c'était pas trop ça à quoi
tu es godet là c'était clairement le
meilleur et après on a eu quand même
greco
avant en italie a longtemps et
leonardo di bucci rouge pas quoi à
l'ouverture italienne quand même
l'ouverture la plus joué au monde un
temps mais maintenant on fait maintenant
ils ont quelques bons grands maîtres
donc louis avocat taureau qui jouent
avec moi clichés qui stresse un peu
d'air il ya
baldoni des deux frères il ya brunello
assesseurs
ils ont le petit sodi il va pas faire
une grande carrière mais je campe à
vannes va de truc c'est que l'homme il
est une insulaire il les sardes il fait
pas trop de tournois il joue beaucoup
là-bas et
cliquer sur chaise comme
il ya un célèbre polymathe aussi
leonardo davinci qui était joueur
d'échecs qui a même écrit un ouvrage
d'échec davinci code non non vraiment
avec patchouli petit traité sur l'ennui
c'est un livre d'échecs avec pacelli qui
est le père de la comptabilité moderne
alors que david peters il est à l'air
vraiment utile luxembourgeois mais
maintenant il a repris la société
italienne
et là il jouait le championnat du monde
avec l'équipe d'italie les députés un
grand temps était très content d'y aller
une belle petite équipe
donc va devoir avec des gens que j'ai
cités y en a d'autres
mais il arrive donc avoir une équipe
avec des dégâts autour de 2006 etc il y
avait vers nick je vais bien maintenant
il s'est surtout mis à donner des cours
il est tranquille et du son fish et joue
plus mais
et tous ces joueurs là il ya vingt ans
il y avait juste pas de grand maître par
codina quoi donc ça a bien progressé
comme
quoi c'est l'étrange cherokee a
peut-être perdu son avantage lors
bizarre hein parce que le fou 2 qui a
été le coup de la turbine c'était
logique floue et 3 soit allait rester
logique aussi enfin cette école côte est
et où le foot c'était fou des 2 1 pour
pousser trois lacs et du juste 30 ans la
droite a pu vous être un
bon coup tu sais pas ça se calcule un
jardin prend b2 sylvain trucs comme eux
cinq
ans verra peut-être c'est pas bon
peut-être de la turbine est trop turbine
est tout cas je vois la pendule qui a
retrouvé un peu vite
richie qui a pris en tout cas
ce que la dette le bon coup et on verra
raj
que qui h5 jouer vers cette offre dont
on avait parlé
famille soit réfléchie en face est bon
on va attendre sur sur la partie
principale dans la partie du jour
game of the day
et des
aspects une partie de partie du tournoi
peut-être un tracé boyard partie de
l'année est reparti de l'année
dans quelques en quelque sorte ça
pourrait être la prépa de l'année parce
que mettre à mal la petrov c'est pas mal
c'est quand même un exploit à ce niveau
cercle carré l'idée h4 c'est très
vicieux ans comme coup pas facile de
mettre hader défaut à un joueur avec le
niveau de préparation
nepomniachi
sépare appelé jeu de mots un
pour les russophones
nepomniachi voulant dire celui qui ne se
rappelle pas
en russe le bien nommé
et plus de 48 minutes un pur pour yann
il y à nous comme on l'appelle
de manière affectueuse
en ligne c'est donc je sais pas de quoi
complexe non je savais lire le chat je
suis pas trop ce que ça
se sera quand
même prendre un petit morceau de
saint-aigulin va donc maintenant je vais
donc
jeu
j'attends le goût de dépôt je reste sur
le coup
une experte chez ce master tu vas voir
sur le twitter de kev vie stream sur
twitter il ya la zone express de la
première heure de jeu
ce que je peux te dire c'est que ma
famille est très bien écrit et blanc
maintenant
reste un peu à convertir et sait faire
les bons choix mais il est mieux clément
après fear je sais pas on est passé vite
fait
car rapporte a bien pris depuis un an
que d'aucunes devait faire et on verra
mais ouais en gros bas fabiano a une
belle idée contre la petrov de dépôt il
l'a mis en difficulté et ne pourra pas
forcément jouer les meilleures choses et
voilà
merci de votre aide
pour le droit français écoutent très
bien j'espère ça t'aidera faut faire des
progrès ça donnera une belle arme
georges hand mjc bon qu'avait parties
ont plus qu'assez de sainté a même
continué on peut en discuter mais là je
crois qu'il ya pas grand chose à
discuter intéressant j'ai dit à peu près
la même chose tous les jours
[Musique]
un temps que le club soit pas vendu j'ai
bien peur que ce sera dur de bien
avancer même si je suis assez content du
mercato enfin des trois joueurs d'un
micron purée ligue 2 c'est pas mal
pas des noms qui font rêver mais bon on
est redescendu en ligue 2 faut y aller
doucement étape par étape je pensais des
bons gars donc on verra
mais sinon à part ça excuse de plus sur
un terrible
ce que j'achète les pendules sont ralph
échec alors bah je sais pas 12000
pendule mais je recommande le prendre
chez alfa échec et pour le stage qu'on
va faire à lisbonne à kiev on va voir se
fournir chez elf échec donc on a shadow
pendule de la vallée chic et ses
terrains
une épaule son petit café qui visitent
bas ont trouvé les infos du stage
je trouve couper le lien mais c'est du
13 au 20 août à lisbonne voilà tu peux
aller voir peut-être sur twitter ou
sinon
je pense que dans les vidéos youtube
vous êtes bien un lien en dessous
et sont de fait l'expérience dans le
shadow blisstree - exactement comme
stunt à 10 et 3 toutes les infos mais
donc c'est en août
mais même si tu peux pas assurer tout
cas elle nous écrire sont prêts à donner
des infos qui ont refait l'an prochain
ou etc et voilà et donc voir une
installation expérience juste là qu'on
recherchait ce club mais pas sur blue
stream bas le raccourci va pas marcher
faire la commande ne va pas marcher et à
la merci à sophie vient de te mettre le
lien voilà donc situer les infos voilà
voilà vous y aura de participants on
doit être autour d'une trentaine
vos acquis au top 3 en échec dans les 5
10 ans bonne question
bon dans un amphi route j'en
garde celle ci n'a pas arrêté et
peut-être un petit nouveau
dans les nouveaux
importants respect des canons au
portugal l'espagne c'est après je fais
un autre stage avec avec maso en fait
prague peu peut-être mais peut-être
enfin tu vois là c'est dur à répondre en
fait
c'est juste un pronostic hasardeux que
je ferais quoi mais j'ai pas
c'est peut être à bout c'est trop grave
ça peut être bien en date peut être tu
vois enfin
bernard beaucoup
peer n 10 qui avait comme fabiano va
décrocher dans cinq ans après je ne sais
pas investissements qu'ils auront qu'il
aura encore
bien
[Musique]
un truc un dépôt qui sut qui sut mettre
en grande calmes ici
[Musique]
l apple a ravi de sa position
nous avons pu rentrer paradis à sa place
on a vu tous les problèmes qu'ils avec
les pièces pas super bien placé et c'est
un conte
et seront un peu fait avec ce terrain je
peux en dire plus sur ce stage avec mike
maso s'est un peu plus tard c'est du 24
au 28 août
proche de barcelone un lieu où on était
déjà là l'an dernier s'appelle santa
suzanna c'était très bien aussi
là tu fais toutes les infos sur mon
twitter c'est mon tout est un gloss
itunes ou sur le stand maso bien sûr est
pareil tu écrire un message privé ou
quoi poser des questions je te répondre
avec plaisir tu verses engage à rien
juste tu peux demander je te donnerai
tous les détails les dates les tarifs
etc et puis après tu vois ça peut le
faire ou pas à proposer des stages sur
des week-ends donc moins longs dans
l'année je crois qu'on va en faire un
15 16 octobre normalement à lyon
donc voilà il ya plein de choses à faire
il fait qu aime bien en ce moment
il fait quoi il a joué la coupe de
france le week-end ils ont gagné avec
son club de manière là la coupe de
france donc il a fait ça sinon j'ai pas
trop ce qu'il fait il va jouer zagreb
dans quelques temps
et puis
tous ces mines a été gagné par clichy en
même temps donc bravo aux filles de
clichy dans mon club big up
à ton retour coaching ce battle rêve et
je crois qu'il est très bien avec vous
mais les bons discours tout mais si je
peux qu'un 1 quand je suis lasse avec
plaisir j'aime bien regarder j'aime bien
suivre donc c'était possible on le fera
je sais s'il reste moins de suivre les
candidats bon je sais pas mais mon avis
oui enfin ça m'étonnerait qu'ils aient
pas moins de 5 des candidats
voilà du coup bah voilà un dépôt quand
je vous dis hein qui pas à son aise mais
on sera moins c'est là ils apprennent
concret et vidé ses qui avait lieu cette
le coup qui semble logique c'est de
faire ça et ce qu'on vous a tout à
l'heure c'est qu'après faburel chambre
qui a valu au 7 ou fouet 4 dans tous les
cas de figure c'est pénible pour les
noirs puisque ce cavalier est attaqué il
doit retourner là bas c'est pas une
super case et les blancs peuvent pas
comprendre 8 dévié l'un ou l'autre
prendre là après a gagné un pion à
l'honneur fois se venger là dessus mais
ken tuch bien donc rien que cette vente
est là ces illustres hâtives et
peut-être peut-être bien qu'on y trouve
quatre c'est encore pire aussi de
conseiller par l'échec
alors né pourra jouer on vient de voir
la cam il a fait bondir le coût attendu
tour s'est vite et donc voilà ma la
famille je pense qu'il va afficher un
petit moment parce que le choix quand je
vous dis c'est qu'il réussit enfin qui a
lieu cette housse ou f4 les deux son nom
et de son nom il ya peut-être une petite
nuance ici ou là mais
voilà
donc on va voir alors quel coup il va
nous jouer
sfr qui nous demandent pourquoi se lever
quand on joue mal à comprendre pourquoi
ils vous attendent leur chaise
bon en fait c'est une manière d'évacuer
un peu la pression de
physiquement tu évacuant fais toi tu
vois quand tu fais un sport car le
tennis ou quoi bon un concours en tapant
la balle tu fais un truc physique là
t'es juste assis
immobile et ça monte tu penses à des
trucs afin de vous ça fait du bien être
l'axé marché des fois tu vas juste huit
bambins vers d'autres postes aux
toilettes et cetera tu te change un peu
l'idée tu peux regarder ce que les
autres font et surtout comment ces
jouets l'aveuglent tu peux penser à ta
parti en me baladant aussi et donc c'est
un peu une manière de gérer le stress je
dirais
ouais c'est charles son stress là en
allant en allant chez way parfait
parfait parfait
trop vite c'est exactement la position
qu'on a vu non on sait pas de wever
s'est pas trouvée nike avait lieu cette
fois f4 si vous fais 4 d'abord godfred
oui oui y'a moyen il ya moyen de faire
des facilités de paiement en échelonnant
mais
bien sûr ne l'est déjà il demande à huit
mois venus de tous pays d'un coup c'est
a besoin de faire en deux fois il veut
payer quoi bah je faisais mais non le
stage avantage en payant une fois
attention dans les chalonnais oui oui
oui oui il en avait pour tout genre de
questions je résiste pas à y faire c'est
demain samedi passé à 1 349 euros le
premier paiement ce 1e re 11e who we r
c'était le moment pub au passage je vais
faire un point d'exclamation shop pour
les vêtements bien oui
il ya du mauvais
points shop la boutique à la base j'ai
mis en grand mais on va les rapetisser
tout de suite là on va un truc beaucoup
plus important oui l'europe
là il voit très bien le roi
et puis deux faces bon ben vous allez
sur le site vous le voyez bitstream
point shop vous tomber dessus il existe
en blanc existe en noir il existe white
t-shirt maillot il ya des choses le
porte-clés faisait que la porte est
basse comme utile un patio de fortes
montées clé vous avez toutes vos clés
avec vrai beaucoup trop lourde c'est
donc là
en blanc il est plus sympa il à la
maison briscoe talent et de haute saône
c'est pour dire une chose pareille
cet accueil blanc prendre noir si tu
pourra comparer à puis surtout si tu
manges espagne et dictons partout dessus
stade noir tu peux peut-être firent
illusion avec le blanc dommage
donc je pense les deux c'est important
pour moi getty et l'autre d'un autre
âge crois que j'aime bien le body blanc
les deux sont bien être de son bien
après à partir de 100 euros total a
livré en fait si tu prends les deux
c'est quasi mon cadeau le deuxième quoi
plus de portes claire jour important
même je pense c'est important
à flot il adore le d'un requin enfin
mannequin oui
il faut un
légume ce qui me croisent et roland
garros avec maso
vous êtes fan de tennis ouais ouais on
aime bien le type
est maso en plus si il joue pas mal je
vous moins bien mais il a passé des
tours là dans ces tournois et gpu de
noël je sais pas j'espère pour lui comme
fleuriste et il est sorti et ouais j'ai
un bon petit jeune qui fait chaud et
ben on aime bien le tennis et on était
très content d'être allé très beau match
franchement c'était cool on a vu sur
tout le match sympa
le souvenir j'aurai un tout cas marquant
c'est la stèle d'arrimage de tsonga qui
a joué contre eux et qui a sorti un gros
match quoi elle n'a pas été transparent
dans ce match loin de là ils méritaient
le cinquième set bah justice et péter
l'épaule à la fin il a plu n'a pas pu
finir enfin la fini mais bon si tu veux
demain quoi
mais bon match très beau match super
ambiance belle cérémonie de fin c'est
émouvant même moi qui ai pas feint pas
fan bien je vais bien tsonga mais
c'était pas moi je suis une fan de
rogers quoi donc cissé rogers ce sera
les larmes qui coulent mais même là il y
avait un peu trop de matches
gagnés pour tsonga non mais c'était avec
quelque chose qui s'est passé avec la
pile est vraiment une belle carrière et
voilà c'était cool et puis les les
autres très bons joueurs français qui
étaient là aussi après pour la cérémonie
bat gaël mais qu'est ce qu'il est venu
gilles simon qui est venu alors qu'il
est son match juste après il a fait
l'effort de venir et puis ce même but il
a fait un super dernier roland il n'a
pas ce que j'entends fin oui c'était
sympa à vivre en ce moment c'est un bon
score
voilà
un f habits réfléchis encore en 54
minutes on est au 21ème coup mais on
sent que c'est ça peut être là la joute
tactiques décisifs de la partie là qui
arrive à fab des coûts pour être faciles
à jouer après ouais
faut six options de fos 4xl 17 ces deux
bons coups mais quand je vous disais un
petit
jeune atp de bâle où federer soit 120
certes sa retraite à l'espère qui va
rejouer l'an prochain comme rogers allez
quoi hop hop hop la
norme si on s'arrête et que j'ai la
chance de le voir jouer en vrai alors si
bâle je suis dispo quoi pourquoi pas en
fait de venir voir jouer à la maison ça
peut être très cool mais au cas où
j'aurais pas le regret quoi ce genre
zizou j'ai jamais vu en vrai dommage
rogers c'est bon je l' ai vu trois fois
d'avis dans un monde où fait ne joue
plus
bavard et 20 de ses joueurs face en ce
moment tu vois c'est quand même le cas
quoi stars qui jouent
à douchanbé quand il a glissé sur son
petit nom tâche chine peut-être
supplique et
à ce patron de la chine le match ou
cissé s'était blessé sabo qui a rien à
entraîner sainte et 10 oh ouais bah ça
va pas trop intéressé il veut une top
équipe je pense dix ou si peu il prendra
là l'équipe de france je pense est
semblable après après deschamps et puis
c'est pas mal
il faut entraîner bordeaux
je pense dit dany levait très peu de
clubs qui peut il pourrait être
intéressé c'est vraiment un fait il veut
pas entraîné pour entraîner quand il
veut il veut gagner ou au moins une
équipe pour gagner et tout faire pour
comme tous les champions et ouais en
fait il est pas là juste votre assise
sur un banc de touche et avoir des
dauphins de partout quoi donc
ouais sainté pas pour tout de suite en
tout cas
non alors cette partie ça se bouge un
peu c'était elle reste très intéressante
un message que c'était mouvementé et
envies dire pendant la première heure de
jeu est là depuis
ça bloque un peu depuis damas quatre oui
on est un passeur il a joué des bons
coups maintenant on va voir l'exécution
quand elle se passe mais en tout cas là
il a bien mené une bonne position car il
a bien je sa prépa il l'a pas foutu en
l'air devant ce qui est dur une phase de
transition importante c'est le premier
coup que tu joues empourprées pas
surfaite comme tu as toujours sans
réfléchir t'es pas super chaud quoi puis
la bombe offre tu réfléchis tu as aussi
la pression ne pas mettre en alerte
après ben tu dis [ __ ] j'ai travaillé
on a passé des mois là dessus à trois ou
quatre que peut être c'est intéressant
je voulais vraiment le coeur qui palpite
heureux mais c'est pas pour faire un
coup il ya le palpitant charlot
ont maintenant ils écoulent falgère très
simplifié l'expérience de ça mais je
veux dire et artois il a passé cette
phase là il a joué des bons coups il a
mené la bonne position et là maintenant
il faut essayer de conclure
avant de conclure déjà prendre un
avantage très concret donc je réponds
plus où ça a changé mauvaise pièce enfin
faire un truc parce que là en fait de la
fusion de dépôt elle est pas belle mais
si tu fais un coup de imprécis ça
revient oui une finale face il ya juste
pas les dames et il manque trois pions
déjà au milieu c'est tu peux vite avoir
des échanges donc il faut pas se tromper
et il refait ces changements il le fait
tout le temps mais on revoit
alors
c'est reparti
c'est encore une quinzaine de secondes
sur cette position et je pense qu'on va
modifier déjà voilà
vous êtes professeur est candidat
oui et non c'est sûrement enfin le ti du
pass huit heures par jour avec nous tu
pourrais passer différemment progressé +
après si tu retiens tous les conseils
qu'on donne et tout ça ça va quand même
t d mais c'est sûrement pas le truc
optimale pour juste progresser cette
envie tu veux progresser tu te fais du
calcul les exercices tu lis des livres
vous des parties toi même tu les
analyses des choses comme ça des plus
actifs
presqu'un viens de regarder aussi non
mais moi je préfère vous soyez vous fait
plaisir mais c'est pas le truc humaine
ou même progresser un temps quand même
des choses là tu vois des parties tu
t'en rappelles
c'est pas inutile en tout cas
ça se rapproche
l'épeuve qui faisait partie de faire
progresser bah oui en fait mais faut
analyser en est sans doute bien
comprendre
je suis ravie là je vais faire fossé est
ok très bien non faut comprendre
pourquoi fawcett quelle est l'idée
derrière puisse mettre des mots en fait
pas que des coups il comprendre et pu
renouveler les mêmes erreurs
et hockey
petit à petit après
rappeler comment ses joueurs tous les
joueurs sont qualifiés pour ce tournoi
alors née peau il est là parce que il
était finaliste du dernier championnat
du monde qu'il a perdu contre quatre
scènes dont qualifié automatiquement ces
deux derniers vainqueurs des candidats
je veux l'an dernier
les autres joueurs alors caruana et
firent ja le joueur français ils sont
qualifiés via le grand suisse un tournoi
open enfin open en 2006 je pense mais
qui était jouée à riga en octobre ou
novembre octobre trois derniers
radjabov un peu ce mini wild card on va
dire ils étaient qualifiés pour les
candidats de 2020 mais il était pâle et
pour cause de kovy des îles sont dit
ouais bon en fait il n'a plus trop tort
on lui réserve une place ici du coup bon
admettons
duda duda et du monde by claude à la
violence était toute à l'écart et qu'il
n'y avait pas de karuïa khimki été
remplacé par ding alé lô
et rapporte et hikaru via les grands
prix
on reste une fête tournoi
[Musique]
haedo a été le plus régulier sur les
doctorats qu'ils ont fait
voilà voilà
alors petit parcours du combattant pour
en arriver là
et s'expliquer lors de ce tournoi madrid
caruana qui a bien compris que c'était
un moment décisif
ouais il a failli jouer
si j'arrête pas au bout de tous les
joueurs bretons pie x priorité au direct
mais en fait dont il s'est ravisé il a
remis la main
complexe
l'ajout ff4 non ouais bah ça beaucoup ça
à wallers équivalent un cavalier 7 en
fait les deux rappels l'autre quoi
et du coup a priori photos qui ces huit
teams semblait commis lors dit là bas et
on verra mais c'est la bombe le manceau
avec un pion plus un côté famille voilà
normalement bas qui cite ce qu'on avait
dit c'est qu'on peut échanger la tour en
8es prendre f5
fait le carré lisse
ou alors ils fameux caillou cette fois
non ouais ça transpose cavaliers au
sérieux c'est trois sets tout cas bien
joué mais au kivu tempo géré c'est bien
joué de sa part d'avoir eu c'est pas
évident de faire qui lui c'est ici bah
ouais
j'espère pour fabi qu'il ya réfléchi
mais
claquettes c'est un bon coup pratique
parce que ça ramène le cavaly enjeux qui
étaient là bas coûts nettement hors-jeu
après leur dis
enfin clairement qui avait lieu cette en
fait
genre il me fait qu'il y ait cette puce
1,71 un autre coup 0,49 et nous
troisième 0,40 avaient parié que celle
qui avait lieu celle ci va avoir
je sais pas
si si si fait confiant sa famille
ouais ça va important
et je saute ça peut relancer les
candidats s'il ne le fait pas et laisse
quand même n'est pas sur la voie royale
mais il va la voir j'en suis sûr femmes
ouais ouais
y'a pourquoi on dit fab et fabiano fabi
quoi chez ba pense que valent même
diminutif
bas c'est peut-être les mecs des achats
qui ont dit fabi mais qu'un autre
fabiano il l'appellerait fab avec
d'autres personnes enfin j'en sais rien
c'est ce n'était pas justement pour et
ses deux intrigues anglophone pour se
différencier de toi en fait abbas a
sûrement non mais c'est quand même là
avant et du coup ils sont et oui fabre
s'est déjà pris tu seras fabi voilà
il n'ya qu'un seul fab
ouais ce qui va avoir
le cavalier cette
séparation
les braves aussi là on arrive à la voir
bon tu as l'air très sûr de faire
confiance je suis très sûr en fait il ya
deux
qu'il faut comprendre pour les blancs
c'est que ça c'est très cool
c'est très cool parce que la torah pour
revenir ici attaqué ça qui doit soutenir
ça et ça m'a un peu beaucoup mais en pls
dans la position mais ça peut arriver à
bien le juger
il va trouver parce que mieux juste à
qu'un autre c'est pas si simple
et donc ouais tout l'intérêt sur
cependant si on rêve s'être fait fin
c'est que sinon s'ils prennent pas ce
cavalier lui les attaques et les deux
cavaliers vise f5 et voilà ça serait
cool le deuxième choix ces roches 8 je
crois que c'est pas terrible
sac et plusieurs en fait en vrai
le prêt est prise mucho problème hausse
sur la colonne des accords mdc mais je
sais pas à qui le souhaite
ou pas ça simple bravo si là il va la
voir
je pense qu'ils avaient lieu cette si le
joug il gagne la partie derrière c'est
pas a dit mais il prend une énorme
option
le truc c'est que normalement il doit la
voir dans
le ranch ça fait quand même un énorme
stop dans cette position à fléchir donc
en fait soit juif 4 vite et je vais
peut-être pas vu mais parce que voilà
mais sinon si tu m'aimes longtemps à ff
iv c'est que d'envisager autre chose
mais quoi d'autre en fait pas te parler
des foulées de quoi enfin je sais pas
donc
n'est pas vous qui a lieu cette on nous
demande à là bas si tu as d'autres coups
tuberculeux fou quoi mais le coût qui
donne vraiment un bon avantage est
peut-être le seul pour gagner c'est qui
a lieu sept
voilà il va être obligé de le trouver un
de façon d'humeur ou une autre il a plus
trop le choix si vous gagnez ses
candidats ouais ah ouais non mais là
c'est qu'il fait 1.662 hommage leur
avons laissé une belle occasion ce que
j'espère juste que la fatigue d'hier va
pas le rattraper quoi
gex doit aller on joue pas depuis trop
longtemps
mais à trois heures de jeu un presque
pour s'alimenter flûte à la fringale
le coup le plus important de l'année et
pour lui c'est un coût important la
fabiano oui clairement
à voir s'y trouvent
s'y trouve pas
il a où il n'a pas
les pots qui avec son beat frey et qui
repart
et dollars - ont plaidé ce que tout à
l'heure
non mais cette fois le replonger dans
les problèmes mais ils n'ont peut-être
pas un scoop
famille va l'avoir
pourquoi le coup un fab vous l'a
expliqué pendant cinq longues minutes on
va par expliquer la même chose en boucle
en fait mais vous pouvez revenir en
arrière inde en live sur twitter en
attendant les vidéos de la chaîne
jean l'autre coup logique faux f1 à
béton allez va pas y avoir un cavale et
ses huit ils y voient là
une caste qui était pas disponible à
cause du roi jusqu'à présent dans
l'autre variante et
si tu fais qui avait lieu cet
assaut en là on va dire histoire et les
f-5 il veut occuper rêver de vrai ouais
mais va récupérer b2b nord sont en place
ouais
voilà après en vrai c'est vraiment que
fin c'est que du calcul et c'est que de
la tactique en fait
lui tu l'as pas dégagé donc ton tour
bientôt reprendre cette ba n'a plus lieu
et ses filles et ses engagements tu vas
faire gaffe entretenir sa qui vient et
être des trucs donc
voilà on fait face ces époques aïe ah
non il n'a pas fait l'info que tu m le
refresh fab
en laye a plus qu'à attendre femme en
fait on a tout dit on a fait le tour de
la position là c'est les joueurs qui ont
la vérité un
trait faut le sortir sous
c'est compliqué tous se ressemblent un
peu faut bien
les bas rhinois
l'inquiète pas ja n ya absolument r
quand un peu la tête à ce mais il va les
trouver
il va le faire il fait des soubresauts
avec son bras il va le faire le cavalier
cette femme tu en as doutez donc pour
fabi ou dépôts
non mais cette partie je serais plutôt
pour familles
pour l'intérêt du tournoi et aussi
j'aime bien le joueur mais je veux dire
moi j'ai rien contre l'epo qui gagnent
ces candidats bravo à lui
sina calais gagne
bravo aussi mais j'y crois enfin je
pense en mon sein des deux mois
ci rapporte les gagne
a priori le mur argent aurait pas gagner
le tour un mail art est le meilleur sur
le 15ème quoi si c'est comme ça
il va le jouer il va le jouer
c'est évident qu'ils la fab
rien d'un shaun pollux est sorti c'est
une prédiction m et là bien sûr qu'on
les a bien influencé pour dire qu'il
l'avait il faut voter sur le non et oui
il faut jouer la cote ici lol quote il
le joue hélas ceux qui ont voté c'est
pas parce que tu vas voter non
voter oui massivement à ces terribles
l'a prédit raté par le modérateur
évidemment
il a joué je t'avais dit aucune panique
fab on peut parler des points nous pour
raser des points chaîne aurait pu bref
cet effort f1 il va la voir
fait important ici le tour à des marges
plus du tout
mais le touran est en marche plus
c'est en
voiture prendre un tas detroit vont
peut-être un tour sept miracles prend le
pouls des fêtes
il va l'avoir non bref un oui
un goût qui paye pas de mine mais ajuste
évite la menace tu retires ton fou tu
ouvres la colonne des pentes à tour
peut-être ce qui est des six dégage
après ta de fou qui revient ces gars
qu'on a vu au tout début il ya longtemps
et 1h ou 1h30 et
guerre
et réfléchie néo polar
il se passe quoi surprendre et 6,20
qu'elle prend des trois en fait
on fait un tout petit tour sur aller
d'être en la justice uricaru parce que
c'est quand même important
réseau rapporte hyper chaud c'est
compliqué il a filé un d'options
meilleur mais il a le fou d'aller perdre
fou et l'afrique à se voir surtout donc
qui empêche le rock donc tourcoing sont
mieux non c'est un choix téméraires
téméraire puisque c'est un sacrifice si
ça ne marche pas tu as d'autres moins tu
vas le regretter mais et peut-être des
chances des attaques ou quoi après
faudra analyser plus que que l'éclair et
na 4 temps dont
4,5 et le royaume uni fait des trucs
logique on est dingue à l'ordi alerte
dire ça marche moyen
mais il ya encore rien de faire fait il
a été obligé de faire rage suite pour
faire f 5 à cause si vous avez 5 direct
avec damas deux
agenais devrait
joli bond que oui forcément les blancs
on serait ravis d'échanger les dames
puisque le roi est plus faible et donc
tu enlèves la plus forte plus adverse
donc moi je suis important on en a parlé
tout à l'heure on était en train de
faire la pause taper le sauciflard
à l'efo f1 encore
ça s'arrête jamais devoir trouver les
coûts
way
we say sens accéder aux bottes des
joueurs de ce niveau c'est que ça reste
les votes les enfants
vont jouer mijn pendant longtemps quoi
difficile
normalement il a fait un choix curieux
cette future va fausser un pic à
l'enchaînement rf7 évidemment c'est un
des deux seuls coups de la position
pour quoi faire bailly d'attaqué et il
n'y a pas beaucoup de bonnes cases
fait tu vas rester sur cette diagonale
pouvoir revenir en c4 par la suite eu
deux cd bildt une vente à tour ces cas
tu peux pas avait 5 tu peux pas t
contrôle et assista pas le droit ben il
restait fin quoi c'est aussi simple que
ça
mais les fous sont généralement bien
placé sur leur case de départ en milieu
de soirée
ouais c'est vrai que ces deux ça
pourrait être une case oui mais non
est plus friable en fait il n'est pas
défendu tu peux pour une fourchette en
retour un jour il ya des petits trucs
l'action jeunes c'est aussi
d'habitude en effet intimement f1 parce
que c'est f1 la case quoi
alors pourquoi ne pas prendre cette
balle peuvent d'ailleurs ce peut-être le
meilleur coup j'en sais rien mais s'ils
prennent en tout cas c'est que les
blancs se venge ici et tout l'idée enfin
montré c'est que là les noirs sont face
à un dilemme la torre attaquer
et le dmp gâteau on va revenir ici ils
ont qui couvrent ici pour pas à
l'essayer blanc sera septième rangée
tour des attaques le fou qui veut pas
aller n'importe où ou s'attaque ça et
puis ben bonne chance là qui avait lui
aussi c'est peut-être ça défend un peu
mais déjà se faire l'option ici à minima
et peut-être le clouage aussi et puis
bon rien que ça je veux dire c'est déjà
très nette c'est un pion de plus les
pièces plus active voilà et puis ce truc
là et jamais tellement prise parce qu'il
ya toujours ça
y avait des barrages mais bon voilà bon
c'est pas de vente trop dur ça
normalement je pense qu'il devrait la
voir
alain il va falloir commencer à
accélérer quand même que des familles
en espérant qu'ils aient le coup
que mine de rien le temps passe un
ouais
le temps passe fab
le temps passe trop vite
faby qui sut
avoir trouvé les coûts
pas simple
c'est le fouet fin qu'il faut avoir un
peu de défauts de
réseaux des autres jours ouais c'est
qu'ils jouent les coûts et wahib bloc
après vrai
moi je suis d'accord avec toi parce que
là je rêve ça tu
t'y attends quand même
moi je suis d'accord avec toi
devrait il devrait jouer plus vite rey
s'est souvent mauvais signe un
mois les bons coups bon sang je peux pas
critiquer aucun de ses coûts mais bon
je suis d'accord avec toi que ça c'est
mauvais signe ses
deux temps qui est un succès
[Musique]
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec toi
radjabov en bonne posture ouais on l'a
vu aussi un oui oui mais bon rien n'est
fait
bobby fischer 45.25 baisse nouveaux
quais bas peut-être
faire compliqué hier 5
enfin de rentrer par des caïds et trop
qui reviennent je pouvais pas assez
nette à seclinois comme le jeu paraît
manquer une défense qu'on n'est pas
oui ça a l'air d'être assez cool
ça si on a plus qu'à attendre
malheureusement
malheureusement ça va se jouer à
sur ce coup les dés sont jetés déjà un
fab
sont heureux
les dés sont jetés et y roulent way
faut attendre
brocade
on est bloqué à deux femmes
ouais bloqués à temps de sa joue
là bas là on a plus que ça à faire
on a vu gignac joue j'essaie de faire
tourner la turbine
enfin ce temps il y monte à 30 32 quand
tu te prépares fo et fin de loin
dont 45 c'est beaucoup plus on va même
pas si jamais un nouveau jusqu'à 45 ans
n'en fait la surface comme en fait c'est
pas vraiment la lier à 39 quand même ils
préfèrent toujours floues en f1 mais
font preuve 5 va aussi
bon a priori c'est bon signe pour fabi
je dis cela aux autres les doigts en
l'air bon quoi il n'y a pas de mauvais
choix
en quelque sorte oui
on va dire de tous ces deux et déjà tu
lâches la casse c4 elle qui a été si ça
peut venir se mettre là dessus il est
très passif et et rien faire
pendant trente-cinq toujours fait fin de
loin de très très long
un
malade
m
franchement même enfer 37 ya pas photo
c'est plus 160 2 0 23
bizarre
ah bah moi je pense qu'il a envie
en 5 10 minutes il est là mais il fait
une petite pause avant de venir
les bravos trois ans et possède quatre
cents à
1900m progression
squad et trouver enfin le fou est
attaqué en fait les gars ont fait un
truc de ce fou donc l'avouer pas là vous
pouvez pas vous pouvez pas vous mais
descazeaux
prétend
mais tu veux faire quoi
on va prendre ça alors
il faut prendre ça que voir beaucoup
plus compliqué que l'autre
mais bien on sait qu'on billets ça rien
on est là dessus harbin on peut dire
facile avait faussé 2 par contre j'aime
pas mince assez visible ce que je vous
dis que c'est de le problème c'est qu'à
ça et en fait pourquoi je dis ça et
c'est pas dur il attaquer il faut qu'il
fasse un truc pour alors maintenant là
il est chiant parce qu'il t'a b2 ya une
case ici qui veut faire une fourchette
sur ça et ils s'activent nouvelle fois
en f1 y a pas une énorme différence en
fait je sais que vous aimez pas rangé le
fou sur sa case départ vous pensez que
ces passifs mais en fait c'est fort il
est très bien ici un fou c'est une
question de porter son f1 en deux au
coin il table et même case là bas ils
dérangent pas la tour qui est déjà passé
ici donc il dérange personne il n'y a
pas d' attaques contre lui donc il
n'interfère pas exode pièce il est très
bien maintenant et noir dans ce débat et
que ceux qui avaient les qui attaque et
c'est leur problème il peut plus venir
là est très actif six barres mal on va
prendre ça et s'ils prennent on prend
bel objet de prendre la tour attaqué
peuvent pas fait et ça on a vu que t'es
pas mal sa toile et revenir là et vous
avez pas le fou dans les pattes alors
voilà après bon pour encore gagner ça
mais sa victoire d un ça va être un
problème pour les noirs qui va arriver
assez vite quoi voilà donc c'est ça
l'histoire du fou est fin et pourquoi
c'est clairement mieux pousser deux
des fours b1 ben je sais pas et la
gueule de la tour aurait peut-être c'est
un coup jouable mais c'est très bizarre
vous couper la connexion du coup lui les
clous et ça peut laisser passer il faut
bien c'est pas naturel facile est
beaucoup moins bon que la tasse on fait
ça pour venir là mais lui il va pas
rester là il a attaqué en fait donc il
va dégager on voit le bouffer et si on
veut faire pousser 4 on va venir c'est
pareil c'est deux coups pour venir là ce
serait un coup pour aller la deuxième
pour venir ici donc en fait il ya pas
photo avec l'ordi voilà c'est très
facile à dire ce que je dis mais
ouais
tout reprend ça
ce genre de truc
ça c'est vrai que c'est plus facile
des surprises on prend le fou
et s'il faut ce bar juste or un
problème hausse il peut faire je pense
oui je sais que c'est la ligne avec ce
temps précise mais c'est clair qu'on est
au candidat qui doit voir on aime
tellement prendre un fou contient le
clouage comme la partie de l'opéra ou
des trucs comme ça ça fait plaisir
donc c'est un réflexe qu'ont à quoi je
précise pas bien belles promesses ici
prend des 3
donc en fait la patiente a regagné
tattoo réattaquer
souvent tu vas peut-être lui d'être en
prise
[Musique]
il craque sur le temps resterez secoue
braques ou tu ça va encore mais
pour enchaîner les coups à fond sur
phalanx chesnais les coins moment
alors là la préparation n'a pas fait
alors aujourd'hui parfois non ouais
juste préparation parfaite parce que si
lorsque j'ai vérifié que les h4 n'a
jamais joué ni par les sommes dues par
les ordi c'est pas du tout les premières
lignes les ramures ligne ni la deuxième
ou le troisième jeu que ça m'étonnerait
si les cinquièmes vous cacher quoi ouais
donc ré selon ce que j'ai vérifié tant
que judith arndt donc ses défauts aussi
dense
2005 la police allaient en fait parie
que ça change pas à 3,5 cette baisse
découle est roi et les magnats conquois
dos façon mondialisée selon ce que j'ai
regardé première collée boys ouais nous
a pris à froid il faut voir que pas
coller ce 3 bosser
quand laissé six f4 et thuram - ouais
conduisait très loin mais bien encore
laissé six au lieu de tout de suite tout
de suite ça c'est pas facile c'est pas
facile donc je pense que ça mérite moins
pas trop d'explications et je sais pas
évident de deux voiliers
la pièce au moment le plus important du
tournoi et la deuxième façon comme quoi
ça a était donc continuer à combler
france
f3
fawcett je travaillais encore assez dur
aussi ça bah je pense que c'est encore
plus dur que ouais mais en fait j'avais
l'impression que cela ressemblait à la
partie d'hier de fabiano grave ça a été
de pire au centre dans les cases noires
et et je pense semble je pense que -
moins de quelque sorte je veux dire ce
que je pense plus tard aurait en quelque
sorte ça ressemble même les positions à
présent sur l'échiquier ressemble un
petit puisque on a vu mieux
donc est ce toi nos amis faux après j'ai
trouvé refuge c'est pas du tout évident
de trouver bien sûr
il ya un conflit il faut bien se rendre
compte du contexte un
truc e fois ci ce bois est incroyable
mussig way 00 27 et moins les noirs
doivent être encore super précis où est
bon en gros impossible mais moi bus
quand je vois ça je vois pas que c'est
un fin moi je pense est gagnant
je pose quelques problèmes fois plus
voilà et c'est que dramatique pour
pour
ne pose c'est que s'ils ne voient pas
les pièces ici ce qu'il est juste trop
bien les grecs à damas quatre c'est une
option l'autre option c'était d'un mode
et bien ça y est d'ailleurs j'ai pas
trouvé
qu'est ce qui a de bien pour les noirs
dans sectionnelles c'est quoi
je pense que les deux ce bateau dans les
deux cas je preview de compensation
courir juste un pion tu gagnes ou tu
gagnes pas et d'ailleurs pas trop de
faiblesses pas trop de problèmes je suis
là pour bien la case ya pas d ailleurs
je pense qu'ils ont le leur dis de les
retransmissions dont passe je pense que
c'est au tour de plus en
voilà donc ok oui le choisit damas
quatre ici le ghana de reproposer délit
est là où il faut après tour et six
jardins x 6 x 4 si je me trompe rsa
parce que oui
les russes y nada maintenant surcharge
peut pas défendre la nina il n'y a pas
de père pète et qu'est ce que ça change
de forme par contre flash 4 6 1 prend au
jeu h et prendre la tour 1 et brun de la
tour maintenant parce que le fou sur
céderait est exact c'est ça
même ça ça n'a pas la gueule très belle
mais peut-être sauvé sa palette sa patte
gauche poubelles non plus oui je pense
est que tu as juste ouais
mais oui c'est dur donc
j'ai vérifié que comme quoi ok
normalement elle les gagnants bottes
[Rires]
il ya plus d'un an il n'y a pas d'europe
il n'ya pas d'animal aussi rapide qui
ont quelquefois shield perdent même si
je suis plus haut
comment s'appelle le plus rapide que je
pars
[Rires]
donc maintenant requise comme
cette foule 5
je veux maintenant au web ok les amis
phare gagne 1 j'ai vérifié trois fois
mais c'est complètement fantasque
complètement impossible de reproduire
sur l'échiquier quoi parce que les
lignes a été collé ce weed fossé
4.6 tout réussi ce que réussissent
collet h5
web si je me trompe
mais alors que valider cinq voix je suis
seul coup qu'on va les grades que le
décale et madame par exemple leurs
oeuvres et ce à gagner mais ok bien sûr
le béton quoi un gros os béton c'est
juste impossible mais j'ai vérifié
pendant très très longtemps que ça
gagner ok moi même si je ne veux pas une
seul espoir qu'il a pu aurait dû le
faire et maintenant alors donc pas
récurrents
bouffard point que réalise obligatoire
donc qu elle est à chf 5 en cours il
faut beaucoup de bouffer
si je me trompe pas il faut bouffer 5
que les cinq
durant tout l or est maintenant soif au
bout de soi qu cobol-it 2,3 au kef au
budo d'abord parce que c'est normal
oui qu'est-ce que ça donc faut des six
tours sweet toerseth
bois ou et wajih si ça peut pas aller
faire aux parois je vis tu es d'accord
je crains pas les rippeurs semblait pas
bien sûr mais on ait l'air hyper sympa
et si le roi se rassure je 8 ou 6 ans
pas que surgisse ok dacquois ici alors
elle joue pour l'activité quand les 2 3
ou est presque l'urcam en bouffer sur
donc ah oui d'ailleurs il prend avec
l'eau l'échec ce que vit tellement
important donc et maintenant les
variantes un peu
bizarre cette web 6
août
un
salaire de
samsa 5 sony always je pense ça sans
qu'il soit ici ça nulle part contre
c'est nulle part contre enfants telle
est l'impression
est ce que c'est très dommage bien sûr
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'elle joue sur un
chic et maintenant
la pression qu'on a ou et donc mieux
faire [ __ ] ont évoqué les trois c'est
bien le style des ponts plus où est tout
à fait oui à l'instar de fischer il a
bordeaux ils adorent de contre attaquer
une fois sa pièce
contre-attaqué
d'ailleurs comme peut-être n'importe qui
et les joueurs de la neige dure briand
sont tous bien imprégnées pour ça parce
que là les nageurs je pense que dans la
plupart des cas en deux rencontres les
poussées j 5 des banques et dans la baie
de chesapeake son titre
c'est bien la levure tueur pour
imprégner ça alors faut sans que les 521
colette oif les amis j'ai peur j'ai peur
j'ai peur que si aujourd'hui il frappe
un peu trop tard
qui au cas moins 20 points d'écart ou ok
c'est pas fini fini et quand même
quoique ok je perds pas encore l'espoir
parce que malgré tout comme les banques
et sinon qu'est ce qu'il a qu'est ce qui
arrive sur le lac de nakamura il est en
train de sauter pas top
dis moi toi tu trouves comment cette
décision en ce moment du tournoi
après les victoires de fière de jouer
alors la
berline avec le
pensais que tu as essayé justement plus
dynamique est bizarre c'est radjabov qui
a refusé la répétition au début
un blizzard ou pas je les remets ici
il lui fait ça il paraît revient bon si
l'envié revient s'il connaissait cette
suite les règles les vôtres je vais vite
d'ailleurs il y des sureaux phobie 6,7
et collègues de ça si parfois c'est une
phobie six collègues douche sous peu
à suivre moi
je dis une connerie
probable bafana menveo face à rennes je
suppose
probable du coût élevé du ca et la fille
père longtemps à carreaux et
pions
c'est un temps bien sûr pour les noirs
mme par contre le pion c'est un pion
ouais il n'avait pas ça trop vite parce
qu'ils sont ouverts des échanges je sais
pas l'un ou l'autre d'ailleurs l'aide ou
les finesses du coût d'un mode
rush un bien
à 6 h c'est pourquoi je sais pas ça
devrait pas trop regarder raddad
essayant de comprendre
cinq
qu'il doit y avoir une explication quant
à eux peut-être 5e f sidamo 5 au lycée 6
6 3 5 2 6 4 et des terrains pour
permettre de bouffer sur ce site plus
tard les aidons car si c'est peut-être
un coup de tampon quelque chose et donc
il veut au provoqué d'urgent pouces 5
plus tard et la dame défend f2 où et
pour qui le plus aux 9-12 serré emprise
c'est subtil
ok mon retour j'ai rejoué le f5 tour g2
et comme on est comme ça
ok mais maintenant il ya moins on veut
offrir faut 3 wii
confirmé par la turbine
parce que n'oublions pas ici en arrive
de
défendre le roi les perspectives cabrol
et bouge à 5 à 6 bat suit la dame est en
quelque sorte faut 3 photo af le
haut-nkam way you lie aux cavaliers sur
f5 aussi
peut-être pas définitivement pour un
petit moment sur ça c'est génial mais je
pense que les badges rire et en plus
lille il n' est maniée mieux au niveau
du temps c'est un signe que ça se passe
mal pour karkwa d'ailleurs à l'heure je
pense qu'ils ont il devrait y avoir des
finances de la préparation après 2 e au
8e à 5 et maintenant je pense l'écho
avec les besoins en or avec le noir ou
peut être avec les deux couleurs je
pense qu'il est excitant à jouer à
où si c'est pas ici
ici on peut prendre le piano ou c'est
pas ici fossé 6 buts c'est que le 5e set
je sais pas je pense qu'ils violent des
news par l'écho et qu'eric je pense
essayer ça je pense je pense je pense
pas que je me trompe vers séoul en fait
c'est clair c'est cougnaud déjà c'est de
ceux connus comme ans et j'ai vu les
fichiers comment il faut le faire donc
je pense que à l'heure hikaru étaient
très bien préparés pour cela a trop
élevé nous formulons et d'accès aux
surprises 1ère dame se doutent peut-être
sivignon comme une petite surprise dames
cette caisse qui est ado plus haut
on puisque [ __ ] ici ça veut pas jouer
quand même
au quidam auxerre et maintenant à 4
c'est peut-être son truc qui est pas
très bon
oui plutôt tiré la fois nous trouver un
auteur se tape alors peut-être un truc
enfin je suis pas du tout spécial ici
mais plutôt dire qu il est évident
qu libre 8
peut-être parce qu'après que les bolides
peut-être
peut-être il faut faire soit tour en
soit ce soir et jusqu'au h3 pourtour
euros pour clio pack collector donc
alors
je suis pour que les bouts de seins et
peut-être ce n'est que le début des
analyses
voilà juste intéressant comme on peut
trouver dans cette merde la civi il a
fait ça elle est partie et dans les
lignes archi achi jouer en fait c'est au
hameau ni aux
écoutes on va voir ce qu'il a joué non
il réfléchit toujours on en est là
peut-être le tournoi caruana sa joie oui
oui mais bon allez je crée des trois
logiques
- qu'est-ce qui les commandent il est
d'une anguille oui oui oui glisse oui
mais qu'est ce qu'il glisse
c'est vraiment décevant ça
il a joué moi jouer et comment pour me
battre aller au fond de folles de
trouver un truc de chocolat un groupe
complet quoi
d'accord ici ils font un coup un petit
peu finir comme tueur
4s qui ont bouffé sur b2
les questions
de toute apparence un peu
quoique you see maintenant john fawcett
il n'y a pas tout de suite y'a pas de
truites à chaque fois à cause de
querelles de 6 ici non il n'ya pas deux
fois trois non plus parce que dirt 3
je veux dire alors que je vais mettre
mon corps allait sur des six le pion sur
f4 jouer j'en ai
encore les dessine peut-être
une petite domination
entre qui sont oui
et auquel siph a bouffé bouffe pas
football de l heure quoi d'autre
quand les 4l plus beauf ou non d'enfants
tour f 4 ou 2 et c'est quoi les
punitions un toubib 4 parce que je sais
tombe à la fin
d'accord d'accord
non salaires aux salaires quelque chose
les liens très étroits ou les aider de
l'attak peut-être doctoraux 4 alors en
tant que les décisions pratiques pour
juste un truc pas mal j'aime bien
qui pourrait s'appeler pour des
initiatives
senio l'ici bas je pense que
objectivement senio louer mais les bras
se mue en
bresse est incroyable 6,6 des chats
passe à 5 1
ça fait très très long terme en fait
les conclusions qui prépare une
[Musique]
grosse nouveauté il est beaucoup
beaucoup plus important d'analyser les
profondeurs et les lignes pour forte
harry que les lignes principales ce que
vaut de toute façon personne ne va pas
faire l'écho de l'ordi un pierce 11 ou
spears on
ouais en fait sa première réflexion à
fabi c'était là un de choix entre
celui-là est celui-là
oui d'ailleurs
je sais pas ce qu'est ce qui pourrait
vous aider pour un prêt d'un mode de jeu
c'est bien possible que les troupes des
trucs alors qu'ils avaient besoin parce
que la tactique n'est pas habituel non
mais c'est un peu
exotique je pense que les choses par io
parce que y'a rien qui
justifie de peu à rentrer avec le jeune
suisse
toi tu aimerais bien signer google ouais
je connais pas trop tard
pour
l'intérêt du tournoi sait déjà c'est
déjà cool
alors au niveau du temps à il a commencé
avec un très grande car autant
maintenant l'est que 13 minutes et
quelques contre 30 2
bat il est vrai le temps est arrivé pour
[ __ ] des riches il spécial pour
les rôles de choses voilà d'où les
questions
si on a pourtant tenu est-ce qu il aille
ou des raisons pratiques pour fait
bouillir
d'abandonner beaucoup plus tôt à la
forte présence de l'énergie les
pressions étaient bien foutues quand
même et comme ça pendant j'ai pas
cinquante coups et puteaux 92 pas et
peut-être des raisons quand même c'est
vrai que c'est pas très pratique c'est
vrai que c'est détestable pour le public
mais aujourd'hui il y aurait pu devenir
frais
voire d'un moto collé
comme jérôme perdu la bataille mais pas
la guerre
sainte journée d'avril et de juin
perdant contre à jean
allard est faite deux jours de suite et
die die maintenant
pour eux c3f 6
ou b6 les tactiques bizarre
avec les des rois f5 thorgal ok
regardons peut-être un petit peu cette
ligne et à tour 2000 certes moqués cette
ligne touche pas au tour de huit
policiers ce premier tour de weeds tour
de 4e volet bouton
ok ce sens cofosa que c'est la même
chose
bouffe
cavaliers
c4as je veux dire que la 14e 6
à
4 locaux vont peut-être avoir des
problèmes c'est pas si nul que ça
d'ailleurs quand
même et peut-être pas que 5
ou est vrai qu'il est quelque part
- au moins le contrôle d'internet
n'aurait
donc voilà il pose
ici ce que vous allez à 4 le truc delà
d'un succès il faut venez ici serait
parfait pour les blancs parce que le cas
mais l'île en prison et là avec leur a
bien sûr pas possible donc il faut
partir juste pas quelque part ok sinon
elle va revenir défendre découvert que
c'est nul d'ailleurs que bull qui
demandent pas trop de précisions
by
préfère tour 4 4
ah
oui parce que si on joue sur deux
au bout
ou ce set encore pour la domination donc
les bois comme ça garde les cases des
six pour le corps que six mois après
tour 2 par contre si beau pays si ce que
peut-être il faut aussi je pense que ce
que les 2,6 et tout était en cours
ça peut être un petit demi nationale
puisque le dossier sera justice puis en
bouche tu devais te réussit ce fait et
comme ça
on garde quoi
lors des dix ans
le pôle
hockey est problématique
après six tours 2
maintenant il fait ce tour de wild fund
ii 8e voulait des 6 euros à quelques
poire cavalli
b767 à fossettes parce qu'on est con
quoi le fou et très fort
avec le quand on joue sur les deux côtés
validé quand il se sent croît de 5 au
lieu de trois
colette des rois de cadre à roye 5,83
d'accord france ouais
ça ça
ok ça ça gagne pas c'est m le fou est
trop
connu ce type de position en fait
ça se gagne pas
par contre
les noirs donc turc alphan manas
au bois dofus est alors jeanne liste
gens disent que globalement il n'y a pas
deux nuls claire quoi oui ça joue sajou
coller des six à quatre et ça joue
encore
comme tu l'as dit alors il peut pas
prendre en attaque là et là toi peux pas
trop venir sur les cases vous l'aimerez
à cause des fourchettes
mais vous qui joue vite alors peut-être
pour faire ça et s'il joue un truc comme
moi je 8 juste par curiosité
j'ai quatre jeux 6 je suis heureuse de
savoir où ça ramène
à oui et je sens qu après et les et des
demandes maintien c'est important qu'ils
posent donc on ne peut pas juste dégager
le roi le cavalier et 5 si facilement
oui
ça c'est bien ça ça c'est bien ça
qu'il faut trouver ça parce qu concernés
pour c'est bien de voir une finale
qu'ils ont toujours un droit
mais par contre il faut quand même
bouger le cul quoi parce qu'il ne reste
que sept minutes 15 secondes de jeu
donc les spectateurs no cry jaffer que
voilà il ya le gaf de rapports peu de
jetons un coup d'oeil
est ce que c'est la peine de s'exciter
ou point quoi oh là qu'est ce que c'est
savait-il et deux pions bat toujours
d'options de retard il a donné tu vois
il sait tous les agathois leurs seins
j'ai donc là voilà j'en avais vu un peu
oui
alors dis aime pas ce coût à trois fois
plus un
jeu c'est pas les cookies 10 h 6 tours
d'essai luis si près c'est pas facile et
du coup ils aiment bien les blancs
ok on voit que le roi est faible en mai
après on va refaire les deux fous eux
six dames g3 à vrai dire pas à l'idée
d'engager trois est juste il faut 5
juste le f
ou
qu'il peut rien tant que joue avec une
tour du moine possible
de toute manière
il trouve les meilleurs courts ou pas
fair où il est complètement clair que
dans ce type de position mais les
terrifiants près possible voire possible
que sur les points donc ça ce centre
c'est comme ça qu'il a eu son coffre
donc là je pense que rien n'est vrai
sans pouvoir trop calculé en ne tenant
pas
comme en iran pour manque de détails je
suis très optimiste pour bien jouer
le joueur pro 4 hir ir - éboué
bravo
des fois être n'est pas aux victoires
furent au meilleur scénario tout à fait
moi j'ai rien moi je suis pas combat qui
j'ai rien contre les défaites de
nakamura non plus dire
je viens un peu car
je reviens après
alors maintenant à soi
kovalev 4 soit fourbe 2 a pas d'autres
cours
logique logique
normalement je connais ce amené paul
devait prendre les traditions vraiment
en avance mais le problème ce que
foucault bien sûr ce normalement mais il
a vu au poids contre que fawcett c'est
un mécanisme pour garder les pièces
noires
ok ok j'espère que maintenant faby va
jouer vite parce que s'ils de contrôle
au niveau du temps qu il aura passé du
temps pour finir votre décompression
il n'y a pas de tour huit parcours
sweetback fouda x 3
patauger 6 thp adroit jeu 8 un gros ça
joue quoi ça jour ces pagnes l'accord
très famille fogel à tt attendent à
la 4 40
40 13 12 coups c'est pas qu'il va tomber
c'est qu'il va peut être précis non il a
fallu absolument abandonné hier trois
heures plus tôt ah non il n'a pas fait à
aulas qu'est ce que c'est pas faim qui
est ce que c'est parfois au mahatma
l'auteur que jose bouffer sur toi qui
est ce que c'est pas fin
[Musique]
au s1 d'autres sans aucun doute
x 3
voies là en allant des moments qui a
voit peut-être alors qu'on décide l eau
le cours du tournoi quoi
voilà mais qu'est ce qu'ils ont et
comment dire il a tué son propre
avantage
trois décisions
la magyar damas quatre alors tandis que
madame de gandhi d'un pion puis donc ou
qu'il n'a pas trouvé les victoires
fantasme ça se comprend mais faut trois
quarts masse il et je suppose le sort de
la partie et maintenant
avec ce thème là et avec cette position
là non c'est bon
l'écart
d'un point d'un point nakamura risque
fortement de
se soigner de nouveau après les
victoires de ya un gros pas de bélie
news sur les fronts aujourd'hui quoi
et peut-être qu'en plus il n'a qu'un mot
rappeur énorme opération pour n'est pour
un cas comment il
y avait eu le foot est roi et bah il est
malin à kavala
d'ailleurs très marrant ce que le 13ème
mois lorsque le feu suppose qu'il ya
près de cinq secondes et les besoins
défendu pio élevée potter bouger bay
est comme ça les pires ont cavalé
quoique ok c'est deux points de plus que
nous
aïe but this
way la connerie en combinant du de nulle
part ça elle voit tout de suite
ouais donc à près de 5 il faut être
précis quand même très pression
parce que leurs dix d'entre eux deux moi
je connais pas un être humain qui va
jouer pour deux enfants me laisse ça au
oui non non il n'y a pas de raisonnement
ce qu'il raconte là il veut faire son
truc oui ok vous lieu d'amener tout ce
qui est d'abord celle de danse rock et
heureuse tu joues pas d'ailleurs je
comprends toujours pas pourquoi 2 2 et
si tout allait donc savoir at il défendu
en avance
oui avec sept tours l'est pas avec
l'autre - écoutez c'est pas un coût qui
traverse mon esprit non quoi
c'est dur en fait à d'autres ce dôme g4
qui est bizarre aussi dans ce cas là
c'est hyper bien joué
dans de 5 à ces bosses
il a beaucoup du tarn en cours il est
vrai mais
où là haut un bravo bravo jeu qui va
dire bravo de 50 ans qui ont
un coût pratique
alors on ne va pas jouer mais on n'est
pas où va s'en sortir
à priori
à jouer ok donc fait les pions vous
prend à 3 francs 1,7
ok certain peut pas jouer autour de 8 en
cours parce que je sais des emprises
moyens je suppose il ya juste pour un
des coups qui sont corrects comme juste
je pars tour quelque part sauf à
8,8
suppose tout bon et une fois la base
j'ai tort oui et voilà
d'ailleurs
c'est est ce que je me trompe pour celle
du type de la finale qui n'est pas gagné
de contre voilà où on découvrira au
candidat dernier
avant une finale est complètement nul
mais qu'elle est réussie de gagner le
wiki sais pas ce qu'il va faire contre
fabi mais ok certes ça y est les bons
ont peur du tout après tout les atouts
de la pression parce que j'en aurais pu
compter sur les faiblesses sur jeu c'est
une fois le four va sera menée sur les
fuites de défendre ça y est c'est plus
faible est ok y'a qu'il est noir qui
peut vous dire qu'ils ont un atout et
les bois
alors vous allez voir fillon a priori
hayat rues d'alger 3 ok mais là on peut
lui faire confiance
il est fou très possible de mouvements
qui le voit jouer le reste de la partie
un peu en
juin l'une des trois premières lignes et
ça ça pose les silures et obtenir de
tels types d'oppositions chaque jour ça
y est ce sera peut-être pas moins d'eux
mais bien plus sur deux
malheureusement elle le problème c'est
que le sauteur selon courant il ne donne
pas rapport ce qui va
mais c'est par contre c'est normal aussi
que rapporte arrive au moins onze ans
parce que plus 50 pour us est bien trop
et j'ai beaucoup de réussite ouais
là sera trop faible en
nombre à bien sûr ici c'est un régal de
du jeu avec les banques parce qu'un pur
mois est offert une grosse connerie est
quand même bon jour les joueurs c'est un
couple tout ce qui arrive souvent des
bailleurs a j'oubliai c'était quoi
l'ouverture
4,5 continue rhinoise oui
avec turroques qui est des quatre mois
je m'en mords moi ça
ah oui d'accord et ici ils savent pas
qu'ils ont appris au bout 3
oui il faut jouer à 5 pour après que les
c4 voir four cet écart des arrivées
ouais ça elle ne se veut pas
au bas qui jouent toutes les voitures
normales pour arriver là après telle
elle qu'il écrit lourau de vaud se
dit quoi
[Rires]
voilà
oui à rien de plus qu aux cauchemars
risque de se défendre avec un tel peu
peur sur huit et avec une telle sûr je
suis
pas s'ils vont pouvoir passible
d'ailleurs qu'il s'il donne plus en et
quelques mois en fait c'est déjà plus
très possible
après ok sur l'idée que je vois cg66 à
quoi
je ne vois pas de pas d'autorité mais ça
m'étonnerait à quoi que soit j'ai six
tours f12 déjà
pardon
non mais ok to rivedoux ils jouent comme
des quatre noms justice
dodik est sûre doivent se sacrifier
c'est quoi quoique un peu le jeu est
plutôt juste 5 x 1 et après donc ça a
été mal compris
oui donc un peu ficelé félicité presque
le public français qui doit partir
d'aujourd'hui presque sûr que furent
sierra ones en est ce que donc voir bien
remonté le moral ce que quand même peut
être important pour nous tous parce que
comme ça peut-être rabat et renée pokam
1 dans la deuxième partie tour le
nouveau bureau
est très dure a pas trop de poids
d'europe
[Rires]
aujourd'hui de la chanson
made off with joue les petrov deux fois
et les choses moi l'eau voire foot you
do fois les formes
benbiou comment l'auteur joue ça vaut le
coup d'essayer monsieur d'ailleurs parce
que les auteurs of god pour fou et 3g
pas
[Musique]
voilà c'est ça ce que je dis depuis
quelques années il faut absolument il te
faut absolument un logiciel pendant les
parties qui te donne pas les cours mais
qui te donne mais la situation dans le
tournoi tu dois abondent sur l'épaisseur
abandonner maintenant ou pas un che ce
tracker oui or voilà
parce qu'ils ont écoutée quand même je
pense qu'il joue point com - oui il peut
aujourd'hui
ouais ça c'est ce que dit vlad qui a
mieux fait d'être d'abord donné d'art et
de l'énergie est plus en forme mais il
est un peu lent et la fuite de milliers
de 36 ans du duc des coûts et pas très
saignant à un moment où deux a pu
trouver des bons des coûts plus fort
vois pas ce que je sais pas maintenant
par exemple le bo5 bocca où il faut être
précis
ce que ça parce que c'est lui il fonce
le pire ailleurs
il en reste encore oui coup au frère de
cinq bus 4 c c'est du coup facile à
faire et puis
que les prix si coin parce qu'après cinq
tours de dos je suppose aussi à tour à 3
et l'idée que voulait encore y croire
donc après 2,5 il n'y a pas tous deux
non plus parce que collet en plus il est
pas mal les pots dans ce genre de
situation non aux airs c'est comme ça
qu'il faut vite faire
trouver les pièges il est peut-être le
milliardaire avec l'accord
est arrivé voilà aussi bien sûr et firo
avance thomas
des quatre
majeurs un petit peu plus de choisy
justice
je vois pas trop de raison d'être
et maintenant il va [ __ ] beauce un
tour 2,8 et l'asie voire un piège
quelque part c'est sûr connaissant le
loustic ou y
parce que c'est bizarre hockey en plus
aux bruyères l'eau
bouillonne en jouant publicis ou et il
veut le débris qui a joué un tour de 6
ans joue cavalier c6 ici tour66
en joue pour eux trois
pour que ya pas de convoler à al
kaoualich 4
jf pour ses catalogues histoire 4 tu
peux
sur un torse
6h joosten je pense que je joue est
prévu ou la contre attaque sur l'autre
corps et
l'esprit oui delta contre attaque
peut-être loupé turcotte est ce que tu
penses à suffire à contre krikor
mais pour amour
est archi-favori un récit perd pas sale
la webapp à la paire d'entre eux sont
même est-ce qu'il va gagner croître la
deuxième partie du tournoi feu rouge ou
contribuer avec les besoins
de quelque chose quoi
et n'a qu'à ils s'en sortent pas
d'accord il a trouvé une super idée
et les médias n'ont pratiquement
apparence juste fantastique
ayew d'objets qu'adam g iii l ai trouvé
incroyable matin et quie et ses 80 ans
défend et il va envoyer son truc pour
une touche non matin bravo hadja oula
oula mes bras j'ai rien à dire bravo
coin et d'ailleurs qu'en valais 6 6 à 9
mois - foire parce que peut-être comme
ça en donne trop de jouer contre joue
avec le pion à eux qui bouge le colonial
carrière sur ce qui arrive maintenant
ouais ouais ouais ça devient un peu trop
bordelais quoi
sabrer bien la pause ok quoique au
québec mais plutôt de pas compter sur la
colline 6
ok bouge on a mûri et oui le fou sont
querellés soit 2 5 requis 200 pour
attaquer les dom
et qu'est ce que ça donne pas faire un
tour j'ai trois échanges et bouffer cinq
et ces six
là c'est trop sale a pas mal hein non
l'est pas leur après tous trois jouent
aux cadres pour
bouffer avec son pion
pour avoir de l'espérance quoi
je préfère tour à tresses
[Musique]
je veux 4,6 est un moment
enfin je veux roi gf2 cavaliers
bon ça jouer un petit peu du tour 2 des
champions il n'a pas fait qu'ali et ses
4 6 5 aux tirs et ses six cbcb il a
roulé sur six oui le haut donc les entre
la casa 7 et ils contrôlent les cases de
8 ou 6 po et changer la tour qui défend
le 15 à 8 et ils veulent attaquer sans
caution passage à la taxe que
j'avais revient d'ailleurs éventuelle
mois elle peut d'ailleurs pas que
l'opinion
a dû faire ça il ya moyen djadja auquel
est très bien firoud ça m'étonnerait ici
n'a qu'à s'en sort bien
il a reculé cette tour mais bon c'est la
fusion convient de taylor qui était très
bien en juin
pareil qui aujourd'hui en tant que
défenseur rap oies et aussi
bien que son adversaire d'hier donc
doublé one voice le retors aaa les
éclairages les compètes cacher des warm
à bouaye soit la position avec 6 4
face
à valérie qui est maintenant une fois
l'opinion ne bouge pas trop ça va oui
n'est pas pas été scénariste justice de
baie saint quihouët v5 c'est le coup
facile un
lot principe décrit
il ya très très longtemps ballet final
les pions passé doit être poussée
poussée de l'eau doivent être poussés
sinon pourquoi un connaisseur pourquoi
tu joues quoi pourquoi taylor donc pas
qu'il faille avoir trois gains et une
nulle aujourd'hui de gains et de cadeaux
trad jaffuel
déjà jake west georgia je dois dire que
depuis hier j'aime bien les partis sauf
que dans ces parties depuis hier il
manque un élément de suspense donc que
les poppers
est devenue juste presque parfait les
participantes et tout mais son point
d'écart enercon oui hélas il a
il a pris du temps pour jeter aux
saucisses parce que c'est la culture
c'est clair c'est le col est que les
futurs cadres et les
mécontents nous tous bon ok nul
d'ailleurs en connaissant le personnage
je sais que ce sont eux qui va prendre
cher aujourd'hui un peu en vue
en connaissant le personnage pu ou voulu
assurer son équipe son équipe
préparent les excuses
personnelles numéro 8 watts en oui mais
il y avait deux possibilités d'annuler
ados de l'égalité mais il y en avait
aussi 3e 4e jouable
mais elles doivent trouver des excuses
mais ils sont déjà en train de les
chercher ils ont trouvé déjà longtemps
parce que je nous allons tous en sait
comment elles se portent à près d un
truc
fou je sais bon il sert appliquée aux et
les joueurs de l'île de la réunion
jir elle est vide
c'est que veut dire que en défendant 5
il veut alors que les deux bouts d'os
comme l'hebdo tour bicis et pour
vous c'est moi
qui
aurais 6-6-6
coller deux trois
ou plus et ça c'est bien je vois est ok
ok alors f4 joueurs attendent la fin et
après on va
il reste une minute 2 2 me contre 15
presque 16 minutes
oui on va voir deux secondes
c'est une bonne tête toujours on dire
non non il va gagner en moyenne
bah je donne 80 15%
droit est trop faible le fou très bien
car je demande à un truc suffisant
retour est là tu vois j'ai surtout rêve
quatre dames g5 pourrait même des tours
point f7 ils se regardent et maryse et
des échecs machin ça va pas marcher mais
même un tel truc pourrait marcher bon il
va faire ça elle ramenée dans toutes ces
belles pièces à l'attack peut-être que
lui leur apprendre je sais pas il ya
1000 milles cible
chez vous l'a déjà dit jah jah l'autre
là
ça prend forme il a bien défendu son
cavalier va pour envoyer lui un petit
peu qui est ce qu'il joue bien c'est
parti les réseaux huit minutes il lui
reste dix coups à la tête on veut sans
qu'au passage n'ont quand même
pas de bisou à un truc halana k ou
[Rires]
année c'est pour ça qu'il est si dure à
battre en fait ouais ouais ce qu elle
tente de les fatiguer enfin c'est que ce
truc
voix céleste d'ailleurs c'est un talent
naturel est assez rare je pense parce
que de télé mais
c'est chiant je veux pas rares mais
assez rarement dans ma vie quoi le pôle
gare était fantastique
de ce point de vue et les grains de près
de berceuses de makala
et avant
un vieux joueur
où il faut réfléchir et il y en avoir
c'est sur 100 pour ce n'est pas
mon 2 je suppose
vichy jaune était hyper chiant pour ça
ouais
et peut faire une union déjà cavaliers 1
kg 2
dans cette partie va se terminer assez
rapidement ok parce qu'on ne peut
comprend aussi qu'il doit pas répéter la
faute de
[Musique]
il a bien raison ouais gère bien son
tournoi oui moi sont venus avant la
partie le racing est juste là il ya un
petit espoir aux usa y ait le feu des
chèques en c2 honneur d'ailleurs
boutiques non
non je vais dire ne donnait pas trop
cherché à donner pas trop fatigué
d'ailleurs en voiture ou
s'est fait par quelqu'un qui sait
comment jouer comment gagner ce type de
tournoi
il faut vraiment garder de l'énergie
pendant très pragmatique en un tel type
de tournoi donc hier il avait raison en
compte
ding et offert ce qu'il a fait
aujourd'hui il a varié les raisons ok
maintenant ce quasi officiel rouge à la
main ok alors on peut les voir un hacker
oui sans doute ça a été la faute
d'ailleurs d'alireza tête dans ce
tournoi aussi de forcer pour hussien est
grave de
l'aféas 5 ya un truc et il joue vite n'a
qu'à l'excellent soulevé hockey à 6 très
tentante d'une page ou à istres et en os
6 pouces que ce que shérif en ville afin
d' accord que s'il n'a qu'à faire
aujourd'hui c'est terminé pour lui sans
doute il fera trois enfin présents au
camp de
deux points il sera deux points deux
points c'est trop
là je pense
par contre ça ramènerait tout le peloton
tous les warm pool serait se
rapprocherait puisque c'est si firoud
jack gagne puis qu'il rate jamais
en fait il ya un resserrement des warm
up quoi c'est bizarre mais mme ding on
n'en parle pas mais il est là toujours
les bons mais dit il est vrai dans ce
tournoi du visible et la plus rapide au
sein partis qu'ils se cachent pour tout
le reste du tournoi
sur des photos pour qui un nouveau plus
haut
pourtant elle est perdue que sur le
parti et la première dame
a pris la rater des gains quand même un
la beaucoup vendangé un fait quoi d'être
trop grande
n'avions plus
les minutes vacher web grâce à un coup
on verra plus tard on va les voir un peu
les autres plus tôt
peut-être qu'il peut gagner enfin
attentes en mai a pris comme les u15
s'il faut qu'à des retours sur cette
chose
celui d'hier quoique il peut pas jouer
tout faux 4 koleos 5 il faut alors foire
5 dans ce cas là dans ce set j'ai senti
tout seul je sens que j'ai co locataire
et l'a d'ailleurs nous conduire je grave
peut-être à prévoir 5 pas alors à
peut-être pour racisme de
dracy-saint-loup soient volés ou 4
et
et je sais pas quoi
mais bon
malheureusement afu judokas vols hebdo
phobos est
né de rien après collège trois passes
ce que je veux dire quand les c6 est les
dm interview sur bosses est le cavalier
sur ces 6 et puis lorient sur a7 est
bien trop lent trop lente trop lente
mais bon on est comme des espoirs dont
je ça
bouffe
oui
moi je gagne jama daté position on va
voir il en est là en or fillon qui
qui accentue la pression et
mais ici ce que bien c'est que c'est bon
pour les poids de calculer
ok en gros d'ailleurs pour rapporte
c'est une bonne idée de battre
pour sauver de l'énergie oui oui ok mais
à quoi ça sert anaqua du coup bas qui
hélas n'a qu'à qui fait fondre les
arbres à son dieu c'est intéressant
ça peut l'éliminer plus ou moins de la
course sera une course à deux et surtout
un
encore à deux quand même un ennemi à
l'est
un point s'est pas complètement marne en
bon d'accord sur tout avec les drôles de